i'm guessing is just like uh it's it is the
the winner will they just divide the 250 by
amount of points right robert please do correct
me from wrong okay i'm trying to do the math here
it's a little too early for math so don't worry
we're going to cover the chest we don't have to
turn the mathematicians but yes if the rest the
second 250 will be split by win percentage so if
someone's eighty percent of their games they're uh
getting quite a payday i like to hear that i like
to hear that it's definitely very very exciting
i mean do you have any um predictions for today
we're asking the heart any questions first
i don't know what to expect honestly because
sagar doesn't play as much chess not nearly as
much as eric but saga is a very talented player
he's way better known these days for his
commentary and for his journalism and he's an
exceptional human being i have so much respect for
both of these players and i would love to give you
a prediction so i'm going to go with eric rosen
just based on the experience level in online chess
that definitely does sound right eric is also a
streamer i mean sagar does as well but i have seen
eric play a lot of games recently and um you know
whoever wins today will get to play the one and
only levy rosman also known as gotham chess um in
the round of eight so today's match is going to be
extremely extremely exciting i'm hyped i'm
hyped too because we get so much blitz chess and
players are going to be stressed out we get to
just casually talk about their games 75 minutes of
five minute plus one second blitz 45 of the three
plus one the final 25 minutes of bullet chest
nemo i've seen you be playing a lot of bullet on
stream lately so i'm guessing you're excited for
that oh for sure i mean i'm really excited to just
commentate too on one minute bullet just it's uh
it's one of the rarer experiences i think as a
commentator because you don't really get to see
that so i'm definitely very excited i mean the
five plus one blitz is also going to be very
intense i i'm going to make the wild assumption
that the five plus one blitz is going to be the
time format with the most um let's say let's say
you know most solid games let's put it that way
because as we all know as the time gets lower and
lower as we go into one minute bullet chess it's
games tend to you know pieces tend to fly across
the board so this will be very exciting although
you'd be surprised by how many time scrambles you
get in the five minute portion where people are
you know up plus 10 and then all of a sudden
they lose on time so anything can happen in
these formats i love commentating this nemo
i'm so excited to commentate today with you
i can't wait for the games to lift up that's what
i'm always waiting for it will remind everybody
of the prize fund here we were talking about that
at the top we're not gonna be mathematicians they
could figure out their prize funds but really what
they want to do is qualify for the quarterfinals
and keep moving on for sure i mean this is very
very exciting we've chess.com has put up a really
really big price pool and um you know we're having
a lot of fun here so i am super excited to see the
games and i personally much like you know what
robert said i think i do think that eric might be
the slight favorite here just in terms of online
uh chess playing experience so the games i'm sure
are going to be extremely exciting extremely
extremely and we all know how much eric loves
his opening traps um i've been caught in a few of
those myself you know so i do think we'll see some
very exciting games yeah and if we do not see a
stafford gambit today that's the ultimate do as i
say not as i do actually that's like yeah that's
really would be disappointing to many of the
fans who will be tuning in waiting for a stafford
gambit since that's been popularized by eric rosen
yeah for sure i mean eric has made a lot of
openings very popular um through his amazing
youtube and twitch channels so a lot of you guys
might actually be getting um some inspiration
from today's games at least i definitely hope
some of you guys will get inspiration from
today's games oh of course i mean sagar op right
that's that's what we're it's all about right
now we got i am rosen who's been one of the most
instructive chess personalities for many years now
sagar who uh you know maybe newer to the scene
for some people but i like i said i have such
tremendous respect from he's been a journalist
for a long time he's like a great source of
information and reporting and he's also an amazing
chess player people sometimes forget about that
when you play less and end up talking or writing
more but sagar is an amazing amazing asset to
the chess community for sure i mean i've known
sagar uh personally for a few years now as well
he's he's definitely being at i think every
single you know world chess olympiad i've
been to and i'm sure robert is familiar as well
since you've been a coach at a lot of those events
so sagar is an um absolute amazing personality for
sure i'm so curious though the first game we'll be
telling because yesterday we had tanya sanchez
who doesn't play so much online blitz chess she
was quite slow in the early stages of the five
minute and she was saying that you know you get
into this sense of comfort that you have five
minutes rather than three minutes that's so much
extra time and then you kind of needlessly spend
time in the opening so i'm very curious to see
how much preparation these two players have done
and for sagar in particular will he be up to the
task of keeping up on the clock with eric rosen
yeah i mean i do also want to say that preparing
as eric rosen is a bit scary you know because
uh he's got a lot of openings he's got a lot of
things that will pop out at you and you have to
like prepare a lot of things a lot of lines a lot
of variations and i'm just you know for a blitz
game that's a lot of stuff to remember right so
this will be a very very tense match oh absolutely
and these kind of gambits even if they may not
work in a classical game you surprise one in your
opponent they spend half their time just trying
to figure out the first 10 moves in the game that
can work to your benefit it also also can backfire
let's be clear some of these gambits have risks
they are gambits you typically give a pawn or
some sort of material so i'm very curious to see
which eric rosen we get maybe we'll get a calm
air he is a very calm person overall but i
wouldn't be surprised if in the first few games
just to dip his toes in the water if he just
challenges sagar in sort of standard opening fair
i definitely do want to see what eric has prepared
for today i mean we're definitely expecting to see
some of his normal um and by normal i mean the
not so normal openings just to make it clear
whenever we think normal we're usually thinking
stereotypical spanish italians but with eric
you never really know um so by normal of course i
mean eric's normal openings which could be really
anything and of course we'll see how sagar um does
respond i'm not quite familiar with sagar's um
gameplay to be honest but i do think that he is
pretty meticulous so um i'm sure he's prepared
something and i want to see that well i think what
you're saying makes complete sense you've studied
a lot of chess and uh you know you don't really
are not really familiar with him and that makes
sense because he doesn't play so much anymore
and that goes to show that it's been a while
since sagar has dusted off those pieces and
played some of these serious matches but he is
really talented uh he's uh he's like some sharp
play he's a d4 player by trade if i'm not mistaken
so that's going to be an interesting clash of
styles yeah well this will be exciting i mean
he he's uh looking a little bit nervous there i
mean i think eric is still still getting fully set
up so this will be very very intense and i think
one of the things that i'm going to be looking for
today and this uh especially in the longer games
is really like internal gameplay style too because
eric is quite tactical he likes to sacrifice i
had quite a few queens um chucked at me when i
was playing a match against him myself so that
was definitely very exciting um but but you
know this is this is the kind of game play that
excites me you know the kind of sacrifices the
the attacks the aggression um so there's
going to be a lot of very very fun stuff
i'm looking at the chat already going wild let
us know who you're rooting for come on we want
to know who you are rooting for i'm guessing
there will be a lot of soccer fans in the chat
but eric rosen he's got his faithful as well
so i'm curious to see what the breakdown's like
i already see they oh no my
queen means coming through
okay okay oh they're hyped look at that yes let's
go chad this is the kind of energy we want to see
yes oh my gosh you know it's funny because
people accuse me of ignoring chat i'm always
keeping an eye on you what do you think
i'm looking this way for i'm always looking
at the chat but i see everybody there is it
feels pretty rose and heavy right now but
i'm sure on youtube the soccer fans will be loud
and proud for sure for sure um there are a lot
of sagar fans here as well and i'm really happy
to see that it's a lot of we got a good match
up coming and everybody seems to be getting very
pumped and i like this yeah this is going to be
a great battle of two of the best personalities
in chess two of the nicest people and they don't
have to be nice i hope they realize that today
it's not about being gentlemanly they can go and
destroy each other over the board that's what i'm
looking forward to because when you turn these you
know pretty soft-spoken humble people into just
competitive chess players they hold nothing back
that's the kind of atmosphere i like if people
you know always have this impression of chess
players you know like whatever they are in
person is kind of while they're on the board
but i have to admit when i played eric rosen his
personality reflected nothing off his chest and
i was shocked i was so shocked i was like because
for me i mean personally i'm i'm quite outspoken
in person in real life and on the board
i'm like very similar but then there's
eric who uh you know is very very polite very kind
very nice and then all of a sudden on the board
i'm just getting destroyed and i'm like oh so that
happened yep you know so this is going to be very
interesting for sure and we do have liftoff i
am seeing game one is underway sagar's rating
is lower than i would have expected 2224 that's
a sign of somebody who is not playing a lot of
blitz which means the increment will be helpful
and look we have already d3 on the second move
against the car con eric playing a quiet setup and
sagar taking over the center here with d5 and e5
yep this is um all right at least the opening
for this one is starting out fairly slow
whoa okay d forcing he goes d3 and then d4 what
is in his bag of tricks okay never mind i said
that and ignore what i said ignore what i said and
forget that he's breaking the opening principles
he went d3 then went d4 he put his knight in front
of his bishop he goes bishop d3 this move makes
sense to me he's protecting the pawn e4 he wants
to take with the knight on e4 but open the board
stayed up black's king is in the center so white's
castling here i think black's just continued the
development knight to e7 makes sense with bishop
g4 all right sagar is ready for a fight okay i'm
liking this he goes bishop g4 straight away i this
is this is this has become very aggressive i mean
the ponds already on d4 castle uh black needs to
probably castle really soon or he'll run into a
bit of trouble with his own king so yeah expect
97 castle because knight f6 everybody would be a
blunder e5 what happened and then you put a piece
in the e file when the bishop takes the pawn that
king is in the center that's not good so instead
we got 97 perfect response and now castling is
going to happen but look at eric just continuing
as if he's not down upon even material in his mind
but i think his point is after pawn takes d5 he
will win back this pawn on d4 and black will be
left with an isolated queen pawn honestly i think
i think eric is thinking right now ah just a pawn
you know that's not enough gotta give a little bit
more and i'm now looking to see if eric talks to
himself while he plays because he's so used to
streaming and just calmly telling everybody oh
well i've blown it upon you know i've seen so many
of his streams and his clips where he's just you
know even when he's blundering he's the nicest guy
in the world like he's the person you don't want
to beat in chess because chess players at least
at the you know this high level they often they
enjoy their opponent's suffering eric is just too
kind you know he's like oh well here my opponent
no they they blundered their queen and i'm gonna
checkmate them oh okay one of my favorite like you
know interactions with eric was one time when i
made a really good move and he was like your brain
is so big and me having never really interacted
with somebody quite so wholesome because
my community is is a little bit you know
we're we're not we're not necessarily the
most wholesome i was just like in shock i was
like is he is he you know being sarcastic or is
he being completely honest and then everybody
of course explained to me that eric is very
very wholesome and he genuinely meant that so i
will until my deathbed i will remember my brain
is very big as my favorite ever compliment that's
awesome well you know both of these players still
they have you know nothing too tense has
happen at the moment there's been two pawns
uh traded off here bishop b8 well i think we
know what's planned here is bit queen to d6
let's go for an eventual checkmate
on this uh dark square diagonal here
but that doesn't look realistic right nemo there's
a knight on f3 a knight on d4 you'd have to
take both of these knights down and i think that
eric's gonna see this coming and on top of it i'm
sure g3 is also a fairly solid move uh in response
to queen d6 so i'm not quite sure what soccer's
plan is going to be in this position i think
i definitely prefer white just because black
i'm sorry about that is that you have your
attention please you have you have my attention
that scared me honestly i thought you
were about to be taken by a ufo yeah i uh
wow oh well you know it's amazing i know
from experience you have my attention
sir you have all of our attention everyone
on twitch on youtube facebook i don't know
where you're watching this but you have our
attention and this game also has our attention
but that is one of those things that happens
you can't control that no need to be embarrassed
i'm so sorry about that everybody i am i
guess apparently my apartment just loves to
wake people up and like at 10 a.m with a fire
alarm well i just want to make sure is everything
okay yeah everything's fine it's just a test okay
good because you never know when it's the real
deal and i want to make sure that you're prepared
and yeah for sure i mean if there was actual fire
don't worry i will i will go out of the building
oh well look at that that was that was funny well
here we see that cyrus queen has went from d6 to
f6 putting some pressure on this knight and f3 but
right now it's very compact for eric all his minor
pieces working together very well but it goes from
you know you need to be active and he goes knight
h2 because the position was solid but you need to
actually create threats and he wants to trade
bishops and in his up with his knight on g4 so
what do you think about this nemo um i i do like
white's position i think a lot more i think like
these these isolated pawn structures where black
does not get an attack in um are just end up being
very uncomfortable end games right as we know um
isolated pawns structures you kind of don't want
to exchange the minor pieces because if you go
into an end game well the major pieces the rook
and queens are really going to just double up on
the d-pawn and there's always the breakthrough
with the c pawn so um it's it's the long run it's
the end game that i'm worried about for sagar
in this position and i mean i mean that aside i
think i think knight to g4 looks very very good
here because we've got knight takes f5 and then
possibly queen takes d5 right after so that might
just be a free pawn or or even you know some
bishop takes h6 ideas because we've got a
potential we've got a fire drill that's what we
have we do have a fire drill i hope this one's
not real i at this point at this point if there's
an actual fire i'm just gonna ignore it so like
please it sounds like it sounds like a truck
is backing up onto stream right now that's what
oh my gosh well this knight g4 move was important
because if the knight were on h2 this pawn h3
would be hanging so the knight g4 inclusion
was smart by eric he does win the d5 pawn
but sometimes actually black's position gets
easier to play even though you're down a pawn you
don't have to worry about that anymore you've lost
the pawn so you play a move like queen to g6 and
maybe at some point there will be a sacrifice on
g3 and this king will not be that safe so i think
that cyborg's life is made easier despite the fact
that he's down material yeah i actually do think
that instead of queen takes d5 he did miss the
very good opportunity of playing bishop takes h6
which would have been a move that i would have
maybe expected eric to see but it's also one of
those you know it's it's like the first game of
the match right i don't know if he's done tactics
for 30 minutes beforehand um the chances are he
has not so puzzle rush is not going to kick in
in the first game of the match but i'm definitely
um excited to see some tactics coming up i do like
this queen g6 move um i do think he's aware that
you know and games being down upon are one of the
most uncomfortable things you could possibly get
into yeah and look at eric he's like i don't even
want to calculate bishop takes g3 but look at
sarah he's picking up momentum in the position
h5 and kicking the knight back his queen can move
to f5 later in the game to keep an eye out on this
h3 pawn so i feel like white could be a
little bit stuck and if i'm eric i need
to find a concrete plan at this moment hmm
yeah i mean is the beast upon a free pawn
i i don't know if i'm so brave to
take that pawn but eric says yeah
me neither i i'm up one pawn i don't need to
be greedy and take a second but yeah that you
could have captured that pawn i i just see pot i
take pawn you know that that's that's my mental
i mean it makes it makes sense you should always
be aware when pieces are hanging and i think that
actually wow knight to d3 i was thinking knight
c6 to save the pawn and put pressure on this
bishop here and said knight into d3 he's just
trying to complicate the position maybe there
will be a sack on f2 a sack on g3 all this kind of
stuff that eric needs to keep his eyes on it for
you know what i really like here what queen
xb7 yes it just looks so cool because rick
takes e2 doesn't work since you could take
out okay well rick's ea is probably the much
more solid uh choice here instead of playing
queen takes piece oh he takes it though
he sees he eats but i'm looking at h4 this king
is a bit lonely over here and if you get h4 and
attacking the pawn on g3 and if i have to make
his move g4 this bishop is very happy on the
diagonal i want the f4 square for my knight
going forward so h4 feels like the right play
and look at the clock by the way eric is a minute
sagar down near 30 seconds so he needs to move and
he needs to play with the initiative i would
play h4 right now h4 is a quite an easy move
to make in these kinds of positions just because
there's really a lack of any other other thing oh
wait that was a very fast g4 from eric and i'm not
sure if i like that move is bishop takes h2 um you
could do either move right you could take on h2o
queen d6 played to go from mate but this knight
is coming to f4 and that's just what bothers me
because if this knight's here it's gonna sit here
and h3 is a problem yeah i mean here i think
i think white has to play knight f1 yeah right
knight of one is played with 13 seconds is uh
there's only a one second increment as a reminder
to everybody so it's it's almost 5-0 right
almost five oh just ensuring they do not flag
right and 92 check that means the bishop can't
move because the queen was defending the rook now
the queen isn't so i'm just trying to figure out
what white's moves are going to be i see that i'm
not getting checkmated sure but knight f4 checked
back what if i just keep going like 92 knight f4
or rookie 2 actually that could be strong cutting
the queen's protection of the rook i'm going for
this attack and only five seconds you gotta move
come on queen g6 yep clock yep clock indeed and
now queen g6 it feels a little bit too slow
maybe this knight can come into e3 there it
goes this thing come to f5 and it's eric who's
making progress we've solidified the position
as white and now it's going to be quite rough
yeah the knight comes in and now bishop e3 look
at that that's a pin that you can't get out of
just take a free knight oh no all right well
and sagar is lost on time unfortunately he had
a very very slim chance in that game um on that
one move exactly for one move he had a chance but
that just goes to show you know how strong that
uh both of these players are really i mean eric
played a very very good game and was completely
you know trying to demolish black so uh very well
played game by both of them however we're going to
round two and what is this opening well we have a
you know sort of catelyn style position with the
bishop and the long diagonal and that's why black
pushes through to d4 saying you're not getting it
knight to c3 you're not getting your pawn to d4
so this is somewhat standard fare but i would be
worried about eric's position in the long term you
take and after pawn takes you the semi-open file
you can try to open this bishop up on the long
diagonal i like white in these positions really
i actually really enjoy playing black in these
positions i like going 97 and then e5 and then
i always thought that black actually has a very
good control of the center but of course i mean
it can be very easily undermined right because
white basically has the entire queen side we
see the a3 b4 c5 pawn push uh b5 bomb push so yes
we do see 97 here from eric um probably expecting
an e5 coming up very soon yeah and i you know you
the way white can play is knight a3 maybe knight
c2 to go after this pawn you know okay he goes
knight to d2 still good but if e5 i go rookie one
so black does get this big center so i think
it's just a stylistic choice whereas i feel
like even though my opponent has the center
i'm just trying to hunt it down move after move
and you're like well i have my big center and
i'm going to proudly use that to my advantage
for sure um i mean this is this is gonna lead
to a very exciting position i predict that
yeah i i completely agree and i think
that eric's moves through like queen d6
pawn a5 knight c5 use those dark squares
and eventually this bishop which is stuck
that once that bishop gets to scroll like f5
then white can see yourself being in trouble
um i mean here i just try to see what sagar
is going to play i'm not sure how familiar
he is with these positions but he is
letting his time run a little bit low
yeah in both of these matches and and that's
cool like it's got me a little bit more worried
yeah it could move like a3 that's a move he could
have played in five seconds but he's spending more
time than is needed to make a move like that and
there's so many ideas here for white one idea is
playing like knight h4 open this bishop up on the
long diagonal and then maybe if you allow me to
get my knight to f5 but i also have f4 ideas once
my knight's out the way your queen is on the same
line as my rook so knight h4 is a pretty standard
idea helping this bishop become more powerful but
he's trying to be perfect right now that's what i
think is going on he's not accustomed to playing
chess so much these days at least not online so
you start questioning yourself you try to be a
perfectionist and then you spend too much time so
you don't save it for later when the moments are
more complicated for sure um i mean here after 94
i would my first instinct would be to play f5 but
i don't know if that's a little bit too aggressive
for this moment but i i do think that f5 is one
of those thematic moves in this position you
know and black actually saves a move because
he doesn't have to play f6 first i mean there's no
threat on the e5 pawn he has two knights defending
that e5 pawn so yeah no f5 is one of those
moves that you enjoy in the meantime and then
like 15 moves later like can i play that pawn
back to f6 because my e5 pawn is so weak but
it's in the spirit of the position for
sure nemo to play f5 and i would not be
surprised if eric does that or if he plays me
like pawn a4 you often play a move like this
just to close down the queen side so both options
look very good to me i've always had the time to
be like yo can i push my pawns up can i just store
my paws off the board i'll do that but i do like
to see eric play a little bit more solid today
i think i think he he is warming up to his usual
style i do like f6 also very positional on a4 like
robert said also just stopping uh before ideas
but the thing is c5 happens so quickly here
and this could be a really big problem for
eric going forward this d6 square is this knights
for the taking there are some times where you play
b4 anyway so that your queen if ambassador
happens can get to this diagonal uh knight
h4 ideas still exist knight f to d2 i just know
these positions very well from the white side and
even if black is okay here i just think
it's so much easier to play for white and
it's again stylistic choice more than anything but
i i think eric you can tell by his time manager
right now he doesn't feel at home in this position
i i do think that he regrets not playing i was
okay he he played f5 okay as i was saying that i
was gonna say i do think he regrets not playing
f5 earlier because now i was gonna say the d6
square looks very strong for white tonight i mean
sagar puts it there with barely a moment's
hesitation and um the knight's gonna be comfy
because how do you kick it out really i'm i'm
like looking at the boar i'm trying to figure
out ways you can't move the c6 knight away because
uh white can take on d4 i mean i was looking maybe
thinking maybe rick a5 or take c5 just get it out
but even still it's um it's going to be very oh
yeah he so he he says i don't want to hear any
longer because the queen does defend but this is
still good for white you just take on c5 and it's
the problem with the e5 pawn persists so it takes
uh sorry takes takes and queens d2 for example
this e5 pawn remains a problem i can play queen
c4 check my bishop on g2 is very powerful so
even if this pawn is captured it's going to be
a long-term problem but he takes the bishop oh i
don't like that i don't like that decision oh wait
wait now this night on okay so we've actually
just reversed everything now black's knight on
c5 is going to be very strong not that it's on
an outpost or anything right now but there's
just realistically nothing to contest that night
and the knight is you know attacking both d3 and
you're also potentially threatening to play e4
in the near future after you move your queen
maybe to f6 oh well b6 first and then queen d6
or queen f6 so we do i do like this position a
lot for black i think i think eric is going
to be feeling a lot more comfortable here
yeah it's like now you're clearly a pawn down
before if you took back on c5 you had a direct
threat against this centralized pawn e5 but now
that pawn looks safer i don't see a clear path
forward for sagar and you can tell because he's
spending time he's like oh wait i took on c8 and
now where do i go from here and i get the decision
you take a bishop and so you have at least the
bishop for the cost of the pawn but what black
center it's too massive it's too well defended
so this is going to be a tough rest of the
game for sagar yeah for sure i mean i think
sagar is is feeling it he's down a whole
minute compared to eric right now and
i'm struggling to find a plan here for white
i'm not gonna lie what are you thinking here
yeah plans not finding those maybe like a rook
c2 rook e2 go after the e5 pawn but black can
just play a rook to e8 you know this rook to f8
to e8 or something and keep it defended uh this
knight can always be useful and depending upon
and as you said e4 is on the docket so even if
you get this rook to e2 i'll play e4 with my queen
on d6 or something like that and i'm just pushing
forward so i i don't know what to do and that's
why sagar is spending so much time he's feeling
the pressure of being down upon down one game in
the match and when am i going to get my victories
yeah for sure i okay queesy too i think it's these
kind of positions that are most difficult to play
in blitz where you don't really have tempo when
you don't really have a clear plan right because
if it wasn't over the board game it's a bit
of a different story because then you can sit
there for like 20 minutes and be like ah yes
let me go here here here reroute my pieces and
then decide on something but when it's blitz you
kind of you're kind of looking for plants that
are like two three moves you know and and there's
just nothing like that in this position for white
and i mean queen c2 is obviously hitting the c59
i'm sure i'm sure black can just play b6 here
yeah and b6 you might have to do well you don't
have to but you would drop the a4 pawn otherwise
but i can understand why you wouldn't want to
play b6 the knight feels a little bit looser on c6
and white would not be opposed to taking
that once the knight moves other way from f3
because then the e5 pawn is weaker so i would even
consider knight d2 and knight c4 getting ready to
take this to take this and black's position
looks a bit flimsy honestly yeah maybe maybe
so i actually think maybe now white has ideas to
play maybe knight d2 knight c4 uh hitting the oh
c4 okay so king has to go to h8 and then mcqueen
b5 is the idea going after the pawn with the
queen and the knight is a bit stuck because
the e5 pawn behind it but i'm with you this
looks like you're kind of going off to the side
needlessly and me to remember this knight and c5
is attacking this pawn on d3 so if the queen
never takes on d6 you drop this pawn on d3 with
a fork so queen d6 played to just emphasize that
you cannot take on b6 without dropping material
so yeah this is um
looking i first for like actually i mean in terms
of just the pure position right you wouldn't think
that white is doing that badly i mean it's you
know uh just down a pawn okay wait is the the
queen snapchat this queen no yeah i was like
okay and there's no knight takes d3 because
of queen takes d6 as well maybe the queen would
have been better than i was six in hindsight but
you know hindsight's always 20 20. it's not
never too late you can play queen fc or queen h6
that's a nice move hitting the knight now this
pawn d3 is under attack so bishop f1 i think
by default is the move time hang the piece
hanging a piece hangs the piece oh and sucker will
yeah you know he had that the position he
he couldn't have asked for a better one when he
went pawn to c5 knight d6 he just didn't follow
up precisely and that's the nature of chess
where even if the engine says oh you're better
if you don't find accurate move after
accurate move it could result in
a good position for your opponent and well what
is this opening bishop see from queenie2 wait what
huh like what's why would you put your queen
here that seems completely unnecessary after e5
now he's thinking so this seems like okay
that's why i'm going to play some kind of
delayed king's gambit the king's gambit
deferred i don't know this doesn't look
right from my point of view just knight
c6 bishop g4 all this stuff okay i have
actually never seen a king's gambit play this
way not that i play into a lot of king's gambits
but this is something interesting i'm
not sure if this is home preparation or
i think it's fine for white objectively
speaking the position is okay but there's no
benefit of having your queen on e2 it does defend
the pawn on e4 but a knight c3 would have done the
same and now you have to watch out for knight to
d4 just exploding this pin here maybe he wants to
go queen f2 queen g3 maybe but it feels like i
don't know it just feels like a long story here
but i'll trust eric i'll just say eric okay man
i don't understand your openings your gambits
but it works you know it works if it works
it works and that then we'll leave it at that
yeah and castle so both sides are castling but
now you see the benefit of having these pawns here
where they're more advanced and so you are the one
who can use your pawns as an attack maybe an f5 h3
g4 we all know how those positions go where white
just storms the pawns and the black king gets in
trouble yeah this is going to be one of the more
um oh well i mean after bishop takes f4 it's not
all too unsimilar from you know typical
italian and spanish positions i want to say um
but every single move i'm watching is like i have
never seen something like this before my brain is
just trying to connect the dots you know i'm just
trying to associate this with something i've seen
before and it's just not happening yeah because
the pawn on the attack the italian and the spanish
is an f2 but it does look similar and this d5
idea that is one that you see in that opening
and i think that sagar timed it well and wait can
he just give eric an isolated pawn we saw eric
do that to sagar in the first game i think that
now yes take on here bishop c5 check is possible
i feel like black's pieces are coming to
life i do like this position for black i
am always very insecure about when my opponent has
a bishop no it's wait that's a wait oh no no no
no you can't move your rook from f8
when you're you can't do that this is
one of the very very typical um spanish
ideas actually with the bishop takes f7
yeah this is thematic this is very thematic and oh
and and eric sees that oh no and black was having
such a good position but now after king takes
f7 we have queen c4 um and not only can white
immediately take back on c5 but the king is
actually really weak and i think i think key f8 is
very likely oh there might already be checkmate
yeah i feel like there's a knight g5 because
there's a mate here the sack on h7
this i think the king has to go to g6
i i don't recommend this very often but
king g6 might be the move but you might
get checkmated there too your kids coming to h5
like what i don't think you survived that either
oh this is this is gonna be very rough kg6 knight
knight h4 um king fa knight g5 yeah bishop v6
all right here it comes here comes knight g5 here
goes the checkmate ideas from eric eric's gonna
snap on this we already know that the rook on f1
is so happy knight g5 you have to defend against
check me here you play queen to e7 let's say then
i can oh my gosh oh he he he didn't look at that
look at that checkmate that's what i'm looking
for it would have been very beautiful except
eric just took the bishop oh well now the king's
safe hey this actually isn't so bad you're down
you're down one pawn but there's an
isolated pawn on e4 this queen can
soon go into the d3 square this isn't that
bad all things considered this is a pleasure
it could have been a lot worse it could have
been a lot worse i'm a little bit surprised
that eric let sagar um get off so easily you
know knowing him he would have been like ah yes
i can check my opponent let's do it i
mean i've seen him you know uh oh and now
okay so i get it i get it like he's trying to
set up the smothered checkmate here but maybe
just move like you know queen d7 and you can
block the check with bishop e6 this these end
games won't be that bad for black but i see
the eval bar is really low so i'm guessing
there's like some kind of weird bishop e2 move to
take away the check is what should be played but
it looks strange believe bishop v2 i mean bishop
e2 is a very unnatural move i don't think sagar
will realistically play it so there's also queen
d3 though which is probably the more logical
kind of move because it serves the purpose of
bishop b2 you're stopping the opponent's queen
from going to c4 and you're also attacking you
know the rook on f1 and you're attacking the pawn
on e4 and you're connecting your rooks wow what
a great move however it's you know putting your
queen of so high on the board is very unnatural
it's not something people usually look for so
yeah i like queen e7 and the only reason i see
him with bishop is i'm getting used to this i
never like to use engines and be honest about
it but then i see why is it so good for black
the normal moves that i'm looking at they're
not don't look that good so then it must be
some ridiculous move that nobody's gonna play
so that's how it's a process of elimination at
this point but here you have to play bishop
e6 uh you do not put your king in the corn
yes what were you saying about putting
the king in the corner robert would you
be as kind as to finish your sentence for the
30 000 people we have watching here um yeah i
don't think you should put your king in the corner
because some kind of knight f7 check looks scary
but i think what saga is relying on is this is
one check and once the king comes here if the
knight moves out the way the bishop will be able
to return and block the queen and attack it but
i see the eval bar skyrocket which means
yeah so it's like there must be something
that means e5 looks very strong as well
just like trying to kick this knight out
i want to get my knight to f7 this
bishop isn't exactly well defended either
oh that's it that's it so by playing e5 okay
let me just show this your knight moves away
somewhere let's say that here once i check you i
have knight h6 double check and your bishop falls
because that's a double check and the bishop's
no longer defended there yes this is um looking
most uncomfortable for black i mean honestly
every single move in this position just looks
very uncomfortable for black sigh of relief sigh
of relief knight d2 played you can now h6 the king
has the h7 square to run to cyrus position is all
right and he's well ahead of the clock by the way
i i i do think that e5 still works here i mean or
you can just play knight oh wait eric is playing
very very um timidly timidly yes yeah it does
feel that way can i even take this pawn now
and regain my material because if you pin me
i say ah it's not that big of a pin i'll take
your knight which attacks i i think he can i i'm
not sure i mean maybe maybe eric hasn't had his
you know his empowered tea yet but he is playing
very very timid and that shocks me a little bit
because i'm like i mean this is not that bad for
black at all you know you might be down a pawn but
rook comes onto the second fight and then you
bring the other wreck over and all of a sudden
black has a lot of counter play in this position
i was going to ask do you think that because he's
up two games to none that's why he's not taking
so much risk he just feels like hey i'm leading
this match if everything continues this way i
can just con you know keep that lead i don't
have to risk anything but i think that's a
risk in and of itself when you stop playing
as aggressively because you're trying to protect
your lead that could go wrong as well i think
people think solid play means safe play but
that's not always the case i i definitely agree
with you i think actually in blitz it's always
better to be on the aggressive side of things
and um the reason for this is quite simple right
like if you're the one attacking your opponent has
to be one defending it's always so much more
uncomfortable to be the one defending and if
you just constantly put pressure on your opponent
they're gonna start to like lose a little bit of
hope so um i definitely would say that eric should
be playing aggressive and that's not to even say
that eric is not aggressive he's a very aggressive
player and um him playing so solid is really quite
against like his normal gameplay style so that's
probably the more interesting aspect to me
because if he just played like he would normally
potentially um he might be finding these moves but
he's definitely holding back a little bit yeah
he's going to regret not when the king was on
f8 not playing knight g5 that is definitely
an er rosen type of vicious mating a check
attack excuse me but right now he still has an
extra pawn opposite-colored bishops and saga takes
on f3 he's going to trade and you say i'm down
a pawn but my rook is way better than your rook
in the corner so if you take the pawn will take
back we just see that happen that's powerful rook
keeping your king stuck it on the first
rank keeping your rook tied to the a pawn
so i think black is certainly fine here we'll see
though if black can even play for more somehow
yeah i think this is one of those positions where
it should be a draw but seeing how both players
are running quite low on time you know pieces
might start flying uh however f4 is very solid
choice i mean get you get your bishop out oh
this knight needs to get right here if that
knight gets to f3 black is just cruising in
this game but obviously that's very difficult
every single square going to f3 might be you
know defended but we can hope oh well now
that pawn is winning i think that's what i said
95 wait a second wait a second it's happening
it's happening now now 95 knight f3 is actually
happening that's that checkmating configuration
you know once this knight gets to f3 you just
want to take this pawn in h2 with your rook and
the king is caught so king g6 knight f3 these are
moves that cyrus you know just just go just go and
what does what do you do here because i'm going to
go knight f3 i'm going to go h5 i'm going to go h4
and i'm just going to keep your king locked in the
corner oh getting checkmated oh he just doesn't he
just ignores it here it goes here it goes here it
comes the pawn and oh my god you played g3 to cut
the bishop off so if you can get this to work h4
ah that was great move rook f1 though really good
move rook f1 i can show that after the game
but there was like a really sick mating net
okay but this is winning for black completely
winning for black this king is caught
friendly reminder to everybody that just
because it's the end game does not wait
wait wait that that the pawn oh he dropped
the pod and that's such an important pawn
and this bishop is now protecting me
the rook take the rock it's hanging
oh my gosh what a turn of events there i laughed
my brain hasn't even finished processing the
fact that the pawn dropped and the rook was
already dropped and i'm like yeah i'm laughing
out of like nervousness for both players more
than anything i'm just like what's happening
but now black is up a rook so sagar is going to
get his first victory and after the game i'll show
you that checkmate that we didn't see but that
eric prevented so oh easy 14 points for sagar
all right let's put the analysis board
here so you'll see the live position but
right around where was it around here before rook
f1 if you played some kind of move like rook to b1
h4 bishop c7 and g3 it cuts off the bishop
so if pawn takes pawn rook h2 that's the
exact check mini pattern that we were looking
for is the knight takes away the square and
the rook would land in with checkmate
so that's what we uh we're looking at
yeah i mean it's an end game but as a reminder you
can still get checkmated end game and this is more
of a reminder to myself for all the times when i
just ignore my opponent straight b-lighting for my
king in an end game where there's only like three
pawns left and i just get checkmated and i'm like
so what happened you know and it goes to show that
in the end game the king can be used as a weapon
that's what sagar did he brought his king forward
and he could have kept doing that unfortunately he
moved his pawn too soon dropped the pawn he
still won the game so it's two to one oh we
have one of these fashionable lines look at that
bishop nemo that's a great piece and even though
white is down upon i've seen the likes of mickey
adams and others reminds me of a grenfell reversed
yeah no that's a that's a good call it's a good
call but look at this this bishop is so strong
and i always enjoy these positions from
white's perspective because the pawn is
irrelevant in the current position you can play
f4 there it is protect this knight in the center
your bishop is so powerful keeping the bish1c8
stuck in place i really could not recommend
this position for black but maybe eric is more
familiar than i am and knows how to deal with this
yes i mean i i don't think this is eric's style
position you know we talked a little bit about
how eric has been playing very timid chess um
in his past three games but he's not a timid
player by any you know standard and i think
getting into these positions um unless it's
unless he planned this you know i don't know that
this can't be too comfortable for black because
i i definitely feel like white is going to be
always on the the plus side here i really like
e4 here actually um as i was saying this i like e4
here for white because you can't play d takes e3
you get another amazing pawn to the center i mean
you're blocking off your bishop a little bit but
your knight can always move and you always have
e5 um wow i like that move a lot the e4 allows
you to sacrifice your knight because you want to
put your pawn on the e5 square so that was a cool
tactic there instead sagar i think we understand
his decision making he wants to play brook did
he won and get his pawn back and say my bishop
my knight i have the better pieces on the sport
here um got rook f2d1 yeah
that looks like a juicy one
that's a juicer right there yeah that's a juicer
exactly let me just take my pawn back why not
um i think the position you know you see the
evaluation bar i'm looking at now off the side
here that it says about level slightly better
for white but from a practical point of view
these positions are always difficult for black
to play because this bishop is so strong and if
you ever play bishop c6 you ruin your queenside
pawn structure so it's just about the quality
of the pieces not the quantity at this point
for sure yeah quality quality over quantity
yeah it's even material if you play bishop
b5 and take this knight then you're left
facing off against this bishop for the rest
of the game so he's going for that i guess
it just felt like the right thing to do but i
don't know i still think white retains the edge
the bishop is stronger than this knight
here yeah i i think that this is one of
those positions where being white is just awesome
because you know you have very active pieces but
um if white doesn't play carefully black can um
snap back and take some control of the center
again with work to da and whatever the the b7 pawn
is actually protected now so you also have like
chess play rook c8 so i'm actually kind of curious
to see what sagar is going to do in this position
um because there's not like a clear plan
for white so it's kind of one of those
positions where you sort of have to wait
around and not make your position any worse
yeah that's true because you know if you move
the knight too quickly you can drop his pawn e2
and queen d6 saying all right now if we trade
queens my knight is happy to move out the way
because i fork your rook and your bishop and also
hit this b7 pawn so i actually really like this
move queen d6 and now the question is for eric do
i want to trade queens i have no choice so how am
i going to trade queens the black queen can't
move anywhere to avoid it yeah um i mean here
queen takes a seven not pretty natural i would say
yep i'm actually really curious as to where like i
think bishop to f3 after and then just finding
a nice spot for the knight there's quite a few
right we have e5 we have uh potentially b6 all
those squares are potential for the knight but
you do have to protect your e2 pawn yeah good good
reminder because we would like to move our knight
to a5 or something like that which is playable
in fact because the b7 pawn is weak but i like
as you said bishop f3 or rookie one some
kind of move that just defends this pawn
and then our knight is free to go i like bishop f3
though you're right because i want my rook is tied
down to this rook so bishop f3 says in the event
the rooks get traded my e2 pawn is still defended
yep for sure uh that being said knight a5 does
also look really good okay bishop f3 is is very
natural of course just defending the pawn then
we want to go knight a5 next potentially and that
bishop's so powerful it defends it attacks not a5
coming as we keep talking about and how does black
play here if i gave like two free moves they're
not just like stealing pieces you know what's
the actual strategy for black and okay knight d5
does make sense i would play king f2 no i don't
even want to see a knight get in the e3 square
it may not join we could also play uh d1 um just
pinning the knight which might be really strong
because you know we have some e4 ideas coming and
black does have to respond to that and then you
can't move you can't just move the rook away well
actually okay you just move the work away now this
is this is the part where like end games are so
confusing because you just move the rock away i
guess you can take and then take on e2 right um
that's that's good catch by you though because a
lot of people would think they can't move the rook
because you dropped the pawn but the e2 pawn
loses defender when the bishop takes on d5 so
you're right the rook can move but where to right
if you move your rook say to here my knight comes
into d6 potentially hitting your rook hitting your
bishop i want to trade one pair of rooks for white
so i think 95 now get that night out the way this
looks like very unpleasant position for black
yeah this um
does not look very comfortable i think 95 right
now we've been preparing to play 95 by defending
the the e pawn and um you know perfect spot for
the knight the rook can pretty much only go to d6
and can i take on i'm wondering if i can take on
d5 because there's background checkmates and if
you take with the pawn on d5 you get stuck with
an isolated pawn and a knight against a bishop so
it's a little deep but like in some event like
this where you try to trade trade you can can't
take with the rook because the background
checkmate you have to take with the pawn
and hey that's an isolated pawn and i'm happy
to play against that c7 all this good stuff very
true but what about you know afterward d6 i mean
the knight can't go anywhere right because like
you said there is the background check made
so what if you could put more pressure on it
in in some way that's a really good call that
if this knight were to move i would take in
background checkmate you but e4 the knight
would go to square like e7 or b6 to stop the
the mate so e4 is tempting but
perhaps not entirely accurate
we could try to undermine the notes okay well he
played e5 i was supposed to just f5 maybe but um
i mean e4 is very natural move too i think he
first perfectly fine yeah knight b6 sort of
force because after the trade rook c7 is the movie
you want to play and if the knight was on e7 it'd
be under attack and the b7 pawn now at least the
knight is safer but rook c7 actually still might
just win material your rook gets to the seventh
rank and how do you protect both f7 and b7
uh i think the call is you don't i guess you play
f6 that's at least true yeah that's and then where
does this knight go so this could get kind of
awkward very quickly for white but i think rookies
is objectively a good decision it just becomes
hard because it's tactical you might make it
stuck on the f7 square if you put your knight in
there so he does it i like it eric is up a minute
yeah i would prefer to have the white pieces in
this position for sure but that minute on the
clock that's getting me a bit nervous knight f7 is
my knight ever going to get out of there because
look at that doesn't have any square to
get to from f7 no safe squares there that
could be too much of a risk and he's
thinking well can i get away with it
yeah i think after f7 knight f7 rd7 uh rook takes
c7 special takes seven i maybe this knight d8 yeah
or 96 i think the knight does get out but sagar
is spending a lot of time on this move and that
makes me nice he doesn't wow he does it he's brave
and he goes for it because as you said if the rook
trade happens b7 is defended but the knight gets
out to d6 and if not for the rook trade this b7
pawn is hanging this bishop maybe go to g4 to
hit the e6 pawn hey this is uh looking pretty
interesting here for sure and where else can
you rook d3 there's bishop e2 think about what
changes with every move played your rook gets
in your bishop's way i will trade bishops and
i think bishop v2 look looks good yeah bishop
g4 also but okay here he goes he's gonna take
he's gonna bring his knight out and then watch out
for this king getting checkmated this is going to
be intense i'm going to see uh potentially rick
d7 maybe just trying to keep things complicated
yeah trading the rooks off makes you feel a bit
safer this rook is very strong here but white
is still better as you were saying you know the
knight gets back out to the d6 square or to d8
honestly both look pretty tempting and i feel like
white might even win a pawn in some of these lines
yeah i think that's what i'm like mostly worried
about is that also bishop takes b4 and then you
suddenly get double pawns on the b file and on
top of that the b7 pawn is still hanging you know
yeah and i guess you know rook takes a3 is the
obvious move in quotes but rook d7 he does go for
it but now knight d8 hits both pawns and there he
goes bishop g4 i think which wins this pawn on e6
this oh no you're not strapped wait the knight is
fully knight's trapped okay f5 saves the knight
for the moment but just you can take and then play
king e7 and at best you uh oh oh i mean there was
e5 and then that yeah so you win a pump but this
is still good for black yeah it's still so quite
a comfortable especially now now white's actually
the one with the um isolated pawn on e4 right i
mean not that it matters that much because it's a
minor piece end game but you know white will still
be tied down to protecting that pawn for a while
wasn't it wait wait what ah wait he just moved the
king the king just won the pawn time trouble does
bad things to people but he was trying to get his
bishop to b7 i understand his plan but you know i
think that sauger's like lack of online experience
is coming back to haunt him here this is paul
was hanging for quite a few moves too so i was
huh okay should be two knight c7 yeah or knight
c3 that's even more active than start pushing
this one f4 okay yeah this is gonna be a win in
the bag for eric just push it push him quite and
yeah it's a very straightforward position um
for for white for black to play sorry let's
be a bit careful because this b5 pawn if i
get to capture that then maybe i have some
chances to draw this but i'm already looking
at sacrificing it i know that i shouldn't but
i'm tempted to so 96 is a way better move king
e4 but can i get this pawns up king g3 king e3
no knight check and then pawn push yeah all right
94 oh pom po straight away also works yeah 94
it's like almost soup small oh that's it
okay it would have been stalemate if not for that
h-pawn but oh he's going for checkmate yeah wow
wow wow wow that's really sad turn of events there
for sagar because he was playing extremely well
and this uh will be our final game before taking
the halfway break it's a halftime in the five plus
one portion but it just must be upsetting for him
because he was out playing eric he pushed him back
he traded those final pair of rooks he was
having a nightmare d attacking two pawns
and then he just slipped for one turn he moved
his king which he wanted to do in the end game
but he didn't seize the moment and that allowed
eric to take a two-game lead yeah for sure i mean
sagar was playing really well he's definitely
picking it up after the last two after the two
losses he had at the start and you know this is
this is pretty much he's he's getting warmed up i
think he's getting warmed up i think he's ready to
go and in my opinion eric needs to maybe play less
timid play like his normal self and just really
just be himself you know he's uh he's a very
aggressive player he can be extremely powerful in
tactics and there's no reason to not show that off
in this match currently i mean the last game
he played well for sure but he missed a lot of
tactical potential yeah um in the opening and then
sagar played the rest of the game really well so
definitely a lot of chances a lot of exciting
chess coming from both for sure we're gonna
take our quick break and return we'll get
back to this match between two of the finest
ambassadors the game of chess has stay tuned
everybody you will not want to miss the action
all right and we are back and i'm glad to see
that there is an amazing meme oh we got pulled
up here i actually hadn't i didn't notice this
as we were going live but yeah this is this is
basically me right now i'm casting as my apartment
is is on fire um so yep yep this is a moon
i'm actually gonna make sure that this shows
up on twitter i will make sure that is amazing
shout out to our producer for getting that
up in front of you all that is so funny but
you know it happens i've been commenting a long
time you never know what sounds what sirens
coming from new york city you'll get so i feel
your pain i feel you it's okay i mean nothing
nothing serious happened it was just you know a
practice drill so we're okay we're fine but i am
at least awake now and i'm sure that these players
are very much awake now too after having played
four games already i never realized quite how
slowly five plus one goes you know as somebody who
almost exclusively plays one minute bullet
just i think we've we we've watched already
we i mean it was just a half time so half of 75
is uh you do your math again are you struggling
with your math 37 wait 37.5 okay i'm sure
that was not 37.5 i'm not sure how old it was
okay um anyways there were only four games played
um in quite a long period of time so that is
the conclusion i've arrived at and there's still
going to be a few more games played in the next
30 minutes so um it'll be very very exciting oh
wow i not listen learn never ask nemo for help
uh calculating anything got it except for chess
except for chess but the math you know we're gonna
say that's too much effort no no no i dropped out
of school not gonna lie two days ago so you know
i can no people can no longer make fun of me for
having a math minor because i am no longer doing
my math minor it's okay i don't have math skills
either but i don't even try see that you know
sometimes you just pass that point and we see eric
is playing a more principle it's just like a you
know spanish we got here so this is your bread
and butter nemo right yeah spanish you're happy
central control for white black brings the
bishop out to g4 because white didn't play h3
what do you see in this position um i mean i've
always wondered in these positions if um knight
takes e4 works and the answer is no it does not
work basically because of bishop to d5 so guys
it's not a free pawn okay don't take that
pawn it's it's very very much poisoned
yeah just showing that quick you can't protect
both knights in the diagonal so that would be a
blunder and yeah people ask that all the time
and it's good to show it just that a bishop
hitting the two nights like that wins material
and i mean this is a very very stereotypical
um spanish position and i am obviously you
know quite quite a fan of the spanish so
i am liking i'm enjoying this position a lot
for white i would say i don't think this is
too comfortable like too much of an issue for
white at all honestly probably not one of the
uh more critical eyes for black yes and you know
the center does look well defended right now and
i just in being formed we got a raid from anna
chess so good to see you hope you're doing well
thank you so much for bringing everybody here we
have a great match ahead it's already four games
in it is between international master eric rosen
and international master sagrasha in the i'm not a
gym speech championship four games in three to one
eric rosen right now we like his setup here with
pawns on e4 and d4 but nemo what next right you
have the good looking position but how do you turn
this into something more well um i mean typical
ideas in the spanish or of course you either find
a way to attack on the king side after closing the
center so we might say d5 i always like the idea
of d5 and then h3 or um h3 and then d5 both ideas
work maybe and and the idea of course is to always
push g4 but you usually want to push g4 when the
position when the center is already closed and
uh or you've already set up you know all your
pieces for the attack so you're not just weakening
your king so i'm definitely hoping that this
bishop c2 move means we'll see some excitement
but also having oh there's your there's the
answer there's the excitement you look for
we have pawns staring each other down we've got
the x in the center here and which pawn do you
take do you take any of the pawns or what's going
on with this tension that's always a question you
have to ask yourself i don't mind your move g4
here i yeah i like g4 but then i'm expecting
knight takes g4 i think you know it's probably
after g4 negative g4 is probably not the not
not not like a solid choice or anything like that
and it won't be played in classical but i think in
blitz it's always very effective to um make the
position more complicated yes because there's a
drawback to taking either pawn if you take on
d5 when the knight captures on d5 this bishop
is under attack and black is happy to give up the
knight on f6 and imagine this bishop on e3 if you
take on e5 my knight captures back and there was a
pin so g4 was played and now all eyes are on this
g4 score will there be a capture i feel like sagar
is a solid player more so than a you know he's not
trying to go for tactical flare when it doesn't
exist so knight takes g4 i believe has too much
risk but he does have time he's up half a minute
on the clock will he play knight takes g4 um
i think actually with the mount he's thinking
i'm probably gonna say no i think he takes d4
is probably more solid and wait look at you
calling his shots here and now after knight
takes d4 we can trade some knights in the
center this bishop can end up on g6 and
i don't mind black's position because i see
the eval bar saying oh white is slightly better
but that's right now and it's these types of
positions where white's king gets under fire
later in the game so what has to be very
careful even though i like eric's position
i'm of the opinion that like these kind of like
once white gets c takes d4 in and the bishop g6
and then you get e5 in oh white's pawn like
push on the king side is so scary you know
i mean there's not a lot of pieces like left well
not a lot of pieces that's the only two minor
pieces that really will be swapped off but um it's
still a very very scary kind of middle game end
game potentially for for black because now yeah
we see e5 white has amazing control of the center
um after knight kicks e4 bishop takes c4 i i
really want to see a like you know an f4 as well
even though that's a little bit ambitious but i'm
enjoying this position as white for sure yeah and
one of the key themes of this is pawn on c7 is
not a good pawn so if you can even simplify rather
than uh pressing four which i like those ideas
with you know an eventual f4 and pushing on the
king side if you can play some simple moves like
rook c1 and keep that pawn stuck because black's
main idea is to say i don't that's a knight
position c5 i want to rush my pawn forward
to chisel at your center because if i get d4 e5
becomes weak i'm opening up the board and only
one of us has an overextended kingside position
so that's what i would be looking to stop if i'm
eric and he's spending time he's down a minute on
the clock so that's concerning me about the future
of his position here i just want eric to play
like he normally does you know i mean uh he is
a very aggressive intuitive player if he just
kind of lets it all flow he just like you know
plays like he normally does i think the moves will
come a lot easier to him i think you know he he's
got his hoodie up a little bit he's uh looking a
little bit nervous there is definitely quite wow
because now you have to take on poisson you have
no choice because if you allow this pawn up to f5
you are in big trouble so i do think we'll just
see e takes f3 i know that people think that's
illegal but when your pawn moves two squares
and you can capture right now as if it moved
one hombus on e takes yep i always forget about
this when i do puzzles always every single time i
it's it's just like but the thing is when you
see ampa song on the board you're like i see on
poisson i take compass on you know because it's
so rare but then when you're doing a puzzle you
never see the amphisong it's true and look we
have this pre-moved bishop takes g6 he expected
the episode to come take with the h pawn you want
to capture towards the center keep your pawn on
f7 which also covers white's pass pawn you know on
the e file and i'm worried about this dynamic with
these pawns here i like white's position again
for now i like it but c5 just what i was talking
about this e5 pawn is the target this center is
collapsing which is bad news for white's king
yeah i'm not too sure about that f4 move
i think i would have preferred something
maybe a little bit more solid because that palm
wasn't realistically going to go anywhere so
a lot of pressure could be put on it but now now
white's king is looking a little bit weak the c
pawn is looking a little bit weak um and you know
black black has a lot of chances to just pile up
pieces on the e file and the d file yeah this
c pawn is either a great pass pawn or something
that black is just going to target and try to win
and actually if you trade off pieces of bishop f2
you know i have to calculate i'd use bishop takes
c5 and all that stuff but i don't think bishop
takes c5 works because this queen is overloaded
defending the rook well both works i should say
and so bishop c5 there's rook takes e5 and once
your queen lands on e5 my queen steals your rook
in the corner so this would just win material
for white so that's sad news for uh sagar who
would like to take that pawn and if you can't
take that pawn well that's a healthy past pawn
yep this is um definitely definitely a
very complicated end game and i'm i'm like
starting to like these complicated end games
because they take us out of our comfort zone
um they give us something very exciting to look
at and and here i think rick da is probably
my go-to choice just because that rook hasn't
done anything okay we do see the rook d8 yes
you're playing tactically and i really
like it because rook takes d8 will actually
lose this pawn on c5 by force rook d8 rookie one
check bishop e1 i'm not gonna take your rook i'm
going to take your pawn first you always want to
look can i get that inter mezzo that's a check i
will take your rook next and then black steals
a pawn so there are plenty of tactical lines
in this variation i like rook d8 a lot and we
see that eric trying to figure out he takes on
e5 okay that makes sense rook takes d1 the
c5 pawn remains and this is going to be um
the battle between is the pawn is the password
more powerful or is white's king weaker
really like like that that is what this entire
position is going to end up coming to i mean
the position bar the engine says is equal
um because for the past one white has
a weak king right and if you play c6 that's
the clearest illustration bishop b6 stops
your past pawn while helping a checkmate idea or
maybe it's not checkmate but it's an attack so
i i practically like black's position even
though i should like white position if it's
a classical game i'm taking white i'm saying
okay i'm gonna avoid your checkmates and all
your checks but right now look at this king
move here i saw the eval bar dip queen d5 check
good looking move and you can even just go
back and forth a bit or queen c6 to block
it but i don't want to be passive that's the
thing i don't want to sit in front of the pond
wow well that is very aggressive king move
yeah i don't buy that because even with the
king on g3 if you ever go c6 the bishop
would come out here so i'm not enjoying
this king marching forward i don't i think it's
going back this time ah it's gonna be a draw
wow okay i i would have played on if i was cyber
and this is where the inexperience online comes
in you're up six seconds there's a king on
g3 out in the open i would have tried to win
that game and use time up six seconds when it
when it comes down to these time scrambles um
any amount of time really really helps you so as
a avid bullet player myself that those six seconds
oh yeah you know you already know
that i'm going to prefer this up those
those few precious seconds right and it's not
the position was not winning for black was even
better for black i think it was just kind of a
double-edged position where either side could win
that passport could promote or white's king could
get checkmated but with an extra time if you're a
bullet player you know i need to make the most
of my chances i'm down two points in this match
that could have been a game to cut the lead or
the deficit in half but i like this line that
sagar keeps going back to the knight on c4
and knight f3 we saw this a couple games ago
he did get his knight trapped which was a
sad thing for him but his position was good
for sure i mean i think sagar is playing these
positions uh very confidently which i like i'm
sure he's already thought a little bit about what
he should have done better like what he should
have improved on from last time so we're actually
going to a position we've seen before and um if
you missed the first game between eric and sagar
in this position well sagar really popped off
so that's actually where he got his his one point
so and queen d2 played this time instead of queen
d3 so that's a a little of a nuance here the
queen on d3 may be more susceptible to a bishop
d7 to b5 so let's just park the queen on d2 and
actually that allows rook c4 to be played maybe
that's the biggest difference of all is that rook
c4 if he wanted to win the pawn in this manner
could have been played and there would
have been no pin on the queen on d3
so but okay he goes rook to d1 and we're back
to where we came from in the other yeah this is
looking very very familiar yes it is indeed and
actually i wonder what eric did during the break
and we can ask in the post-match interviews
because i would have looked at the opening
i i don't think he felt truly comfortable here
but he's going right back to it so i i'm curious
if he actually looked at this at all or if he
just said i i was able to hold him off as best
i could let's just go back to it yep this just
looks amazing for white this knight this rook
this bishop this rook coming to c7 this pawn
on b7 is a problem this pawn on f7 is a target
you couldn't ask for a better position nearly 20
moves into the game yeah and i do think you know
it's actually very interesting that
eric got back into this opening
despite how the first game went because i'm
sure it wasn't very comfortable for him and
we can see how sagar is um using has only used 30
seconds for his first 20 moves you know and that's
that's definitely great okay a little bit of a
deviation here right am i yeah yeah the queens
came off in a different manner it's sort of the
same but yes it's not exactly the same and you
made a point earlier the pawn e2 is under attack
maybe just bishop f3 looks strong king can come
to f2 protect that pawn first and then continue
your path forward in a bit but uh something you
just said there about how cyber had only spent 30
seconds that's the biggest thing to me is i cyrus
shown that he's not that comfortable in the blitz
format not yet maybe he's getting it under himself
or maybe he's finally finding his form but i would
try to use the clock as a weapon as best i can
if i'm eric and by going right into sagar's pet
line you allow him to make these 20 moves quickly
and then now when he's thinking he has plenty of
time remaining to figure out how to proceed wait
is there not just bishop takes e2 here there
is but then rook d8 check this b7 pawn hangs
oh rookie a that's that's probably what was missed
and that's you know it's like you take this pawn
rook dhx you assume oh i have to take first
but you're right rookie eight first makes sense
and if i take you take back b7 is defended and
even here white can play rook c1 rook c7 and
i don't think white's any worse but you're
right that that pod can indeed be captured
i mean i think i think eric's now thinking can
i or can i not yeah it's it's one of those moves
where it's probably fine right now but you want
to think where that takes us in the game because
you do not want to win this pawn if it costs you
this pawn on b7 because the queen side majority
will be easier to push the king is close to the
pawns in the center and that's why eric ultimately
decided on king to f8 but he's just going to have
to suffer for the foreseeable future i think rook
d.a here too um is very very similar to the rook
d8 we would have looked at after bishop takes e2
yes and well i think you can do the same thing
take rook c1 try to get this rook to c7 that's
where my eyes are taking me and once your rook
gets to c7 black's in big trouble for sure we
might see king takes e8 here and then if rook
c1 oh okay we're just securing the e2 pawn first
i mean white's seeing no rush right like he he
has all the time in the world to um play roxy one
rook c7 yeah and even actually if the knights and
the rooks come off the board white is still much
better so for example if you play knight d7 and
i trade your bishop takes so this is what might
happen and the rook comes to c1 and you'll rook c8
we trade everything white still is better because
this bishop is an active piece your bishop will
be on c is a defensive piece so i wouldn't be
surprised if we see all that but i guess cyrus
says hey actually i have a tempo to use your
brook can't move yet the pawn on b7 is hanging so
i like the way he's playing this yeah oh what what
whoa whoa whoa that's a pawn that's right here
rook c3 but there's rook to d3 yeah rook d3 just
blocks i'm trying to look at eric's face here the
guy is so stoked he doesn't respond to anything
like he's not even he just is acting as if it's
just another move in a normal game of chess but
he did just drop a pawn but sagar on the other
side he just kind of perked up in his chair
there he's like yeah okay we're gonna get a win
we're gonna go oh yeah let's go let's go i see
i see him yeah yeah he's he's ready to go all
right this is a match we're in the thick of
this thing here and that was a big oversight
by eric but it wasn't a one-move blunder
i don't want to call it i think the pressure got
to him and the pressure not of the match overall
but this specific position i think he needs to
change this if i were his coach i definitely
agree we went to the quicker time controls i
would say eric maybe don't play this line or
just here's something you can do within this line
that makes your life easier but eric right now
eric's probably thinking oh no my pawn in his head
but actually like oh no my pawn for real oh no
not the [ __ ] this this check here would win the
a3 pawn if not for rook to d3 and all right we're
gonna see rook d3 played and i think sagar is just
going to convert this end game it doesn't seem
like it's one where black has too many chances but
weirder things have happened and he is only
one pawn so it's uh not came over just yet
yeah i mean these are the kind of end games that
you actually have to play a little bit accurately
in order to win it's uh the the the d-pawn is not
a pass spawn it's actually an isolated pawn so
now the plan will be to you know potentially
create the past pawn uh on the queen side
because you do have a palm majority there
while at the same time not losing your d-pawn
yeah it takes care of both right your d-pawn
is not protected the bishop can come to c4 and
once this happens the b-pawn is a pass pawn but
it's also a decoy oh i like okay now it's just a
pass pop not even a decoy you're going to put your
pawn to b6 the king will have to sit in front and
then white's king will just march over to the king
side and that's sort of what i meant by decoys you
don't even need your b-pawn to stay on the board
forever as long as it distracts black's king long
enough for white's king to dart over to the king
side yeah this is um one of the positions that i
think sagar is going to pick up and you know the
success of this opening just goes to show that
maybe eric does need to choose another opening um
and as we're going to go into an even faster time
control i think that'll be even more crucial
because sagar having being up two minutes at
40 seconds against eric wow yeah that speaks for
itself doesn't it that definitely does itself and
i'm i'm one of those kind of people who whenever
i play somebody i'm looking at their clock like
the first thing i see is their clock because
uh you know the position is a lot of things but
if you lose on time you lose the game as well
and this is maybe not the best kind of way to
introduce chess to perhaps newer people
but the clock is definitely very important
well that's true in most sports as well right
if you're down a bit you know you you might run
out of time and you can't catch up so i mean look
at this this king is caught king e7 king f8 this
king is going to just hunt down and win all these
pawns this seems like a very straightforward win
and what you're saying about the clock though it's
true that i think eric needs a more double-edged
opening to try to take advantage of the fact that
sucker does not play that much online chess and
that he may find himself in time trouble and may
not be able to play that high caliber chest but
in time trouble that is but sagar wins it's
now three and a half two and a half we have
ourselves a very close match and soccer now gets
the black pieces and just to look at the clock
this might be our last five minute game so if
this game goes as long as the others have this
will be our final game in the longest time patrol
i'm so perplexed by this queenie too move yeah i
don't like i feel like there's a lot of better
ways you know to get the style of a position
um and then queenie two just feels like one of
those moves where it doesn't really do anything
apart from defend e4 but even then i would have
preferred to have just the pawn d3 to protect
e4 so right and if i'm eric i'm thinking about
this because he's playing the same openings
and there was that break i'm like wait did vidit
call up sagar and just like give him some opening
advice like that's what would be in the back of
my head is you know he's got some powerful friends
and if he just gets a phone call hey uh you know
maybe you should look into this line that's what
would concern me so i would be playing kind of i
would dodge i'd be dodging whatever preparation
he might be doing and sar confidently goes
back to the same exact line and he did have
a good position in the previous game before he
blundered this pawn and f7 with check that was
the biggest problem for him yeah i um this is he's
learned his lesson for sure i'm actually really
interested in knowing um like what what exactly
is eric's plan for this entire match because we've
seen the same opening a few times now right like
we've seen them repeat the same stealth opening um
so surely something must change at some point it's
just a matter of i think when but so far this this
this doesn't seem to be causing white any issue
surprisingly this queen e2 move which is very
very funny to me a very perplexing move and eric
sort of got the ideal setup that he was aiming for
he would like to push his pawns over here on the
king side and say i have an attack and that's why
cyro reacted with e takes at f4 he knew that was
coming and with a closed position the attack would
feel even more powerful because black's pieces
were restricted and couldn't fight back so look at
this d4 e4 this is the king's gambit come to life
but even stronger the king is safe and castled
f4 is falling and once that falls the open f file
the bishop on c4 aiming at the f7 upon the black
king i would be very concerned right now for cyrus
something went wrong here and i don't know exactly
what so these people are tricky we're all just
confused about what what to do under queenie too
yeah it's somehow catching everybody off guard
and eric is the one who's well had in the clock so
he's coming up with this tricky opening that sagar
is struggling to meet yeah and this is just one
of those things where it's like he already knows
what didn't work last time so he's not gonna do it
however how do you improve on the spot you know
that's very difficult because it's not like you
have time to just go off and prepare a whole new
repertoire against eric's e4 bishop c4 queen e2
so he's probably here just as confused as we are
95 was a great move though because when you're
getting attacked a lot of people think i just need
to put up a defensive wall and i need to deal with
it directly sometimes you can defend by attacking
your opponent so what sagar is doing is he's
striking in the center first c5 now he takes d4
hello moves like queen b6 knight c6 all this kind
of stuff to go after bl white's pawns and this
gives him the counter play needed so that white
doesn't have the free reign on the king side so i
really like what cyber did knight a5 knight on the
rims often are dim but here it actually dimmed
white's attacking chances and look bishop e3 a
retreating move now you can play knight to b4 go
after this bishop and all of a sudden black is
creating threats and now white doesn't have that
sufficient time to go for a check mining attack
um the pair bishops in this position are
great for eric you know at some point the
e palm will probably move up and then all
of a sudden your paws are just aimed at
okay well as i'm saying that uh sargart knows
he's got to step off those bishops and this is
now all of a sudden black's king feels very safe
right name right now yeah a couple moves ago i was
like wait that pawn enough seven is pinned the
piece in the f file and he's doing everything
right sagar is playing this perfectly to say i was
worse and now i think i'm completely fine i put my
pawn on light square if e5 my knight comes into
the e4 square and it's even material no attack
for white i'm not trying to claim that black is
better in this position but black is definitely
more comfortable so the trajectory of the game has
been in sagar's favor for sure i mean here 94 okay
um knight c3 is pr pretty natural we still have to
develop that night it's almost we're 17 moves and
we haven't developed the night on b1 so it's about
time right next week it's about time it's about
time i mean i always like to tell people and you
know as coach and pakchan i'm sure you tell them
a lot too try to get all your pieces developed
before move 10 or something but here we are
all right move 18 knight finally moved and it's
immediately gone well it's important to note why
sucker took the knight rather than the bishop
if he took this bishop note that this pawn on
d5 is on a light square this bishop cannot on
e7 can't defend this pawn on d5 so in the event
that is a knight against a bishop this knight
would try to eventually come to c3 a queen to f3
and attack the pawn so this is why it's easier
for black to defend queen d7 now just connect
your rooks maybe rook c6 i think that black is
completely fine and there could be a future where
actually soccer takes over the initiative because
this bishop on e3 on the dark squares is defensive
covering the pawns later in the game the bishop
on e7 could be used as an aggressive piece yeah
i mean this is one of those positions where it's
like super super solid um we both have the same
color bishop so uh going into end game that would
just mean that it's realistically a draw because
there's not no significant weaknesses anywhere
however that being said it is you know a blitz
game so there's gonna be probably some action
coming up soon as players run a little bit
lower on time eric is up a whole minute and a
little bit more so that's what that's what's
got me a little bit more concerned i think
i think sagar is like really trying to find
his footing in this position not that's like
a very difficult position to play but whenever
somebody uses a lot of time to spend on the on
any position just it just goes to show you know um
they either have something amazing planned or it's
just not one of the most comfortable positions
yes and you know he plays rooks
what bishop before no oh whoa whoa
rook c3 i get the intention you're trying to
double the c file but let's see eric's face
his even react how's that possible
oh no my rook yeah how is it
possible that he doesn't even react
like that was that's he walked into a pin
he's so casual about he's like
ah well that happened i guess
yeah it's like it's as if this didn't even
happen to him it's like somebody else is
playing this game and he just happens to be on
screen but i mean amazing composure he dropped
his rook and now sagar he's ready to convert
this win this game and even up the match score
wow what a turn of events in this game here
and credit to sagar because he could have
just fallen victim to some kind of checkmate
instead he fended eric off and he did tenaciously
struck in the center he got counter play and now
i would play rook to g6 in the near future to say
let's trade rooks you're never going to attack me
and yeah rook g6 now yep i think this will be a
very uh easy pickup bye stacker and then that's
that's absolutely incredible he played a very
solid game nothing major particularly happened
and you know sometimes it's all chess needs
to be right you just wait for your opponent
to make a mistake you catch them out on
that mistake and then all of a sudden it's
gg yep and the reason why this is so easy now is
because once the rooks get traded black will play
queen a1 and this c3 pawn is gone so bishop g5
that's a good response by eric he's in trouble
no matter what at least keep it a bit complicated
sagar under a minute on the clock making movie h5
is a bit risky so it attacks the rook but that
could backfire you just need to find several
accurate moves to put this game away i think i
would play h6 here just to uh trade the rooks off
and there we go rotates g4 it's hard to make a
mistake in this position it's black it's very
difficult that's true just do not touch this pawn
on g7 yeah that would be the only mistake you can
make is giving up the dark squares on the king
side but with the pawn on g7 nice centralization
pawn on g4 zone attack this rook can do what the
other rook did rook c6 over to g6 perhaps yeah
sagar is going to convert this one yup for sure uh
this is one of those things where it's just like
ah i mean eric is just you know playing along he's
a little he's he's still up a minute on the clock
so you know he hopes that he loses chances but he
knows we all know there's very little chance in
this position for white however it is the last
game of the five plus one anyway so it's not
like he's missing out on anything by finishing
the game right that's good to talk about match
strategy because sometimes let's say there were
30 seconds left in the 5 minute portion you might
just resign to get one final game if you feel
that that's your best chance but for eric no no
he thinks the bullet the quicker time controls
because sagar has been moving more deliberately
throughout this match but right now sagar hasn't
won yet he's down to 28 seconds counting down if
he gets into a bullet scramble with no time left
that's how things go wrong but i love this move
queen a2 rook c4 win this pawn all right no more
i don't even have to worry at first i'm saying you
know 26 seconds 25 it's doesn't he just feel so
bad playing these there's just zero counter play
now the bishop can't even move and like there's
literally nowhere you could go like oh i just
feel bad for eric you know but like soccer just
played such an amazing game so i really really
really respect that and i really respect how he
just like got that advantage just crushed eric
positionally being up the exchange it's just it's
just incredible to see for sure yes and i often
believe that mistakes like the one that eric made
by blundering the exchange walking to a pin it's
caused by something earlier because of course he
sees that bishop before it can be a response but
i feel like he didn't get what he wanted out of
the opening and that may have been weighing on him
a little bit just do not allow by the way there
we go so sarge goes back because you don't allow
any sort of draw here so the queen is coming to
safety this a4 pawn can push the b-pawn can push
and i think soccer's doing everything perfectly
at this point yeah for sure b4 yeah breaking down
the pawn chain d4 is now weak as well that's a
pass pawn just a matter of time that's free yeah
perfect play by soccer yeah absolutely amazing
i mean sagar looks like he's woken up fully
i don't know what else to say because you know
eric was leading the match to to to oh at some
point and then all of a sudden um sakura like
was fighting back and and now and now the match
will be tied after this game and this is the part
where we talked about in terms of strategies at
the start right robert we were talking about how
uh while you're playing this maybe maybe
eric thinks that he can just kind of like
play solid stall out the match he's already
up two points and everything will be fine but
i guess what he didn't expect his sucker to
suddenly be like yes i'm gonna be the one
winning i know i'm down points but i will win
and that is part of the part of chess that um
we all really like because there's always
chances and this this is this is just incredible
well if i'm stuck i'm happy to get this experience
or he's playing in time trouble and he's looking
like a true bullet player he's spending almost
no time for his moves it is a completely winning
position but when you don't play much online
bullet all of a sudden you get to 10 seconds
wait wait and then you blunder things everywhere
so uh sagar he's very confident at this point his
king is coming in he's going to promote
his pawn and he's going to be up rook
brook c3 and then take this bishop and then
get the queen and i know some people like
oh eric should resign why is he not resigning
eric rosen doesn't resign and he actually has
been able to get stalemates because he doesn't
resign yeah there's all those positions but
i'm actually you know if there was queen to f1
that i feel like it's still my trick but i'm sure
sucker would not be falling for that so always
worth the effort you know to try to get stalemated
you never know what happens i mean i can confirm
that there have been games where i should have
resigned like in world championships and it's
just been like i'm not gonna resign and you just
swindle your opponent so it's actually a very very
um important lesson to learn as well from eric to
just you know play the game yeah i mean if you
resign you get zero points if you end up losing
by checkmate you get zero points you can't score
if you resign so i think that eric did the right
thing and speaking of score it is three and a half
three and a half we're gonna take a break and when
we return we'll get to the three minute plus one
second increment time patrol it's excitement here
between sagrasha and eric rosen in this i'm
not gm speeches championship brought to you by
chess.com
all right and welcome back everybody before we
dive into another really exciting portion of the
match between eric and sagar let's talk a little
bit about pogchamps 3 which i know every single
one of you guys is extremely hyped for so here
we can see all the participants in pogchamps 3
and let us know in the chat who you are
cheering for i mean i personally have been
loki following a lot of these people playing
it's so exciting to see like you know people
getting into chess it's such an exciting
thing i've played chess for 18 years of
my life and i haven't probably seen this
much hype um from like the public audience
so i'm personally just like this is like a big
deal for me this is a big big deal for me um but
yeah so i mean i've personally coached michelle
carrey already um robert have you coached anybody
i have indeed and you know i gotta say if i had
to pick a favorite it's ludwig oh yes ludwig i
mean ludwig we we've we're familiar with ryan
we've seen ludwig not only play in pogchamps
we've also seen him cast pog champs we see him
cast he he is an absolutely amazing streamer and
he's you know put in the work for chess as well so
i'm definitely definitely excited to see his game
play this time and i do actually want to point
out that um there's some people including maybe
maybe sir dosh is going to be a very very very
strong player you know not not not saying that
ludwig might doesn't have very good chances of
winning pogchamps um i have seen sir dash spend
hours and hours and hours playing chess and i
think he's personally said he was aiming to go for
like 1500 um by in by by the seventh of february
and uh i i when does pogchamps three start exactly
i need the 14th if i'm not mistaken so around
valentine's day all right around valentine's day
you know awesome none of us have anything to do on
valentine's day anyways perfect um so yeah i mean
there's people with very big aspirations in [ __
] chimps and i'm just so excited about it yeah you
know i won't name any names or anything but some
people are working offline so you know of course
people are streaming a lot of chess but i know you
know from first-hand experience some people may be
working really hard behind the scenes to try to
win pogchamps so you know they're they're people
putting in their work it's a lot of fun to see all
these people play but we're here today for this
matchup between eric rosen and sagrasha i don't
know who's gonna win this match at first i said
eric when we did pre-match predictions but the
last couple games sagar has been finding his form
he's looked excellent he's has really technical
precision and he doesn't give eric chances when he
gets the upper hand so eric needs to find his
footing here we have liftoff in this next game and
knight f3 are we going to get this same line again
nemo ah we might oh i think we're going to get it
we're i think we're getting it guys
um it is three plus one this time
eric is thinking a little bit here so maybe he
doesn't want to repeat it i mean if i was him i
definitely would not want to repeat it however
you know that choice is mine not his so
i think we're gonna get it yeah the problem
is if this is your normal rep oh queen a4 we
have a different line but if this is your normal
repertoire it's hard to like say on the fly i'm
going away from this and he's playing a6 if queen
takes c4 b5 this way the bishop gets to compete
with white's bishop so it's not a one-way street
now both bishops are happy in the long diagonal
but the concession is this is a backwards c pawn
so if i can keep your pawn from getting to c5
white can claim a long-term advantage so black
is going to be looking to get this pawn break
yeah i mean this is also i think the main line
of the catalog wait wait no no that was wrong it
was a blunder you do not allow this the bishop
is under attack it's night it's knight takes
f6 right yes god okay now that the light square
bishop has been traded off okay so first of all
you don't really want to take on a6 because that
bishop will get trapped but that light square
bishop is now going to be an absolute monster and
we already saw how much of a monster the light
squared bishop was uh when black actually had a
light squared bishop right in the previous two
uh times they've played the catalan already now
that there's no more light square bishop for black
that bishop has no contest and it's going to
be a pain for eric to deal with for the rest
of the game yeah and if your sire what you want
to do is leave black with this bishop on g5 it
doesn't necessarily mean that you trade knights
you could trade these two pieces the knight in
the bishop but as long as you leave black with
this dark square bishop that doesn't have targets
you're pretty happy so i would just play knight d2
maybe knight to e4 knight f3 one of these squares
here get my knight over the king side and i think
that white is has the most promising position
out of the opening we've seen all match yep this
is definitely something else i mean we're gonna
see the knight possibly travel to c5 it doesn't
necessarily have to go there but that is a very
very nice square for i mean it is an outpost um
is just you know square ware no pawn can attack
it right so he did step one knight e4 but now he
now he goes step two knight c5 i was waiting for
it but he might be thinking do i really want to
allow that bishop to cash her the answer is yes
because the c7 pawn is so weak you put a work
on c1 do not trade queens on d6 don't do that
do not trade queens here that fixes black's pawn
structure you are playing against this pawn on c7
this is um you know we got we can see either
rick c1 or queen c2 i i kind of like quincy
two more maybe here because if you swap off pieces
it tends to ease up the pressure for your opponent
right because oh well we saw roxy one okay well
it's fine i would have personally preferred to
play queen c2 after a second thought but nothing
wrong with roxy one of course i mean it's a very
natural move to make it's just now i like if you
if queen takes c5 d takes c5 then you no longer
have the pressure on the c file i don't really i
kind of missed my pressure on the c file and now
there's even less pressure on the cfl because you
don't have a c7 pawn anymore so right i think this
has traded a little bit more into equality that is
not to say that white's position is you know it's
not not good anymore but it's just uh probably
queen c2 was the more accurate choice from sagar
yeah this knight c4 there's like a tactic which
seemed unexpected and it was a really good move
by eric a good find but white can still play rook
c2 rook c1 there's only one open file and white
can be first to it so i think that what will
remain better but you're right it doesn't feel
quite as powerful as it oh i like this too because
if you play rook to c8 i can take and try to get
my bishop to b7 where i'll hit a rook and hit
the pawn so bishop f3 was actually quite clever
and this rook would of course love to land on the
c6 square yeah well rook fca is going to be oh
yeah the problem with the bishop b7 lines where
you know you could play rook after ch to show
very quickly but if you take back with the rook
here there's bishop b7 which hits the rook and
the pawn maybe this is okay but it's hard to play
this in a blitz game for sure i do think directly
too and then i mean i'm not gonna try to like you
know contest the line but rick c2 it's also very
interesting end game where you just down a pawn
but you can probably hold it because the rook's
tied down to a2 but of course it's very difficult
to spot these ideas um on the fly so yeah i'd say
the hardest part is evaluating like i know that i
have compensation there my rook is active europe
is passive but is it enough and in a split second
when you're now your white is down to a minute
black is just a minute 15 seconds you you
don't assess it necessarily even if you see
it yeah it's always easier to go for the lines
that where you're just not down material right
i think as humans we are or as the way we've
learned chess it's always easier to just be like
ah i'm not down material therefore i'm fine
right um nothing wrong with that mindset of
course but there's a lot of things outside
of material in chess that impacts the game
absolutely and i'm worried about speaking
of material this pawn on d4 it's on a dark
square it can be attacked and this type of
position where a knight can actually be better
than a bishop as okay i play e5 without even a
second thought and try to use the dark squares
this could be a problem for sagar i love the way
the opening went he had a big advantage but now
things are turning in eric's favor yeah i mean e5
here um i would still say that like you know d5 is
a past pawn however we all know that knights are
the best blockaders of past bonds because it just
sits there yet it still controls all the squares
around it you know so um eric definitely has
a pretty solid chance of actually maybe
turning this end game around in his
favor i mean that the eval bar does say it's
still fairly equal but a few raw moves from
two to remove from sagar and all of a sudden
he could could be completely in black's favor
and if you get too aggressive for black let's say
moving f5 which is probably good in this position
you have to watch out for your other pawn the
pawn chain is only as strong as the base pawn
so this is a pawn chain here and the f7 pawn is
defended but as soon as you make a move like f5
your pawn on g6 could be weak but king see
that the engine did not like that move one bit
so i'm wondering it seems like both players are
missing something but it's hard to figure out
what because the position is pretty locked up not
too many pieces remaining oh okay rookie hey check
you have to because otherwise you're okay i don't
forget they both only have 20 seconds so we can't
really you know expect to see perfection now yeah
perfection definitely go perfection here where i
rookie wait nights yeah that rook is in danger
that is that is one very unhappy looking rook
yeah you can play d6 at some moment to keep it
safe but you lose a pawn maybe g4 but takes takes
his f5 to block the diagonal uh oh it's gonna be
hard to find this with six seconds on the clock
you just gotta go a4 that's a reasonable move
we're gonna try to go a5 to kick this rook away
and look at eric down to 11 seconds he doesn't
want to take on a4 because bishop e2 within
take on b5 actually that frees the rook he made
the move i said which is a blunder now the rook's
trapped king b7 oh no a takes b5 was needed uh
and i mean with that little time on the clock
yeah it's gonna be difficult to find
these accurate moves you know i mean
it's hard enough finding them with in
classical time control that's going to be
near impossible to find them the one time control
so yeah and that move at the end there you know a5
attacking the rook had a clear purpose but if he
was able to take on b5 the rook would have been
free and now we see eric play c4 going away from
this e4 bishops for queen e2 stuff that we kept
questioning oh we're getting a sharper game from
the very beginning so black gets this f5 e4 set
up but whenever you push your pawns like this the
light squares become more vulnerable but for now
it's just uh the opening stage neither side is
unhappy this is um very exciting i mean soccer
seems to be quite well versed in this opening
otherwise i there will be very little reason to
push up your pawns like this as black so i'm going
to assume he knows what he's doing i'm also going
to assume that eric that's what he's doing so
this is going to become a very interesting fight
i i really like these more aggressive openings it
really leads to a lot of excitement on the board
yes and look at this h4 making intentions clear
i'm gonna attack your king but what i don't like
for white is these doubled pawns it's not the
biggest deal right now but i feel and you can
disagree with me it's just maybe a personal
opinion that in blitz having double pawns is
really hard to deal with because you'd like worry
am i gonna lose the pawn for instance pawn c4
can black play b6 c5 bishop a6 very quickly and go
after the pawn these are like the worries that i
have at least and why i try to give my opponents
double pawns even if it causes me to give up
the bishop pair yeah for sure i i definitely
would imagine that um you know this is just
not the best position i i'm not that there's
anything wrong with wise position but it just
feels like where's your king gonna go it feels
very unnatural to play this position as white
in in in blitz because you don't have easy plans
right i mean your one plan would be to possibly
attack on the king's side but at the same time
your king's still in the middle of the board
your dark square bishop is always gonna suffer and
this is like okay well c5 is a very good idea just
trying to open up that dark sword bishop right but
at the cost of the pawn structure you may undouble
your pawns because you may continue taking here
but then you have the split pawns on the queen
side so you're going to have a long term issue
regardless queen e7 is also a interesting move
saying you can't move your pawn your pawn is
pinned to the bishop so you can trade queens
you can play queen e7 i would keep the queens in
the board because white's king is in the center
yeah this is just one of those
positions where i'm like huh
king's in the center let's go queen seventh
let's baby play with the a i mean at this point
even if you potentially um well not that not that
black's at risk of losing a pawn or anything but
you're willing to give up a little bit more
just to keep white's k in the center and white
is still at least two moves from castling on
the king side at this point i don't even know
if he wants the castle looking inside because
he's made the very aggressive choice of playing
h4 but that pawn will become a weakness
if the rook ever moves from h1 right so
cyber thinking but this is i don't think you can
afford to spend this much time here he is now down
over half a minute and he plays queen e7 but if
he was really feeling the position he would just
make that move queen e7 just like you know what
the king in the center like we're talking about
play this move and i'm not saying that's how you
should play chess generally when you're playing
classical time girls don't just rush a move of
course not but in this format you're playing three
minute blitz you just gotta go sometimes for sure
for sure i mean this is intuition is everything in
blitz right you don't have the time to sit down
evaluate calculate and i mean we've we've talked
about how sagar hasn't really played that much
online chess um but he is still very very well
known and he he he is around chess all the time
so at least some of these ideas are coming to him
for sure and queenie five look he did exactly
return my queen default great response by
eric rookie you do not take that queen and help
white's pawn structure so rookie eight saves the
rook from danger on the diagonal it protects the
queen that's a move that you can comfortably play
pretty quickly he did so in what 10 seconds he
can't afford to spend 10 seconds look at the clock
right now he's under a minute eric is a minute and
a half so these little moments they really add up
and i'm not trying to be overly critical of
course not cyber's a fantastic player and
he just isn't used to playing in these quick time
controls and that's what could hurt him but his
position is absolutely fine for sure i think here
maybe we just go knight c6 yeah i like it just
kick the queen away yeah i mean you definitely
don't want to play queen takes e5 because knight
takes e5 and that's just going to be uh a very
very strong knight on a very nice square yes yeah
this is look at white's piece of the bishop on
a3 it's not really everything i feel so scattered
like i i got like my rooks are not connected
we know we like the rook bros my king's still
in the middle of the board my knight is chilling
on f4 i mean that night's actually fine but like
none of the pieces are doing something for the
position like they're just there you know we
don't have a clear plan for white so it's
it must be quite difficult to play this um
okay well now we have h96 there's cheese watch
out for the cheese dude if you take the queen on
d4 you get mated i'm sure that very quickly bring
up the analysis board here because knight takes d4
knight g6 check takes takes the bishop covers
the mate uh the escape score on g8 the rook
will take the knight when it moves and then that
is checkmate so there is cheese do not fall for
it he doesn't he's still thinking queen takes f4
is a good move because there it is and take the
queen now but he spent so much time he spent
so much time to get here but he's much better
because of the light square control the knight is
way better than the dark sword bishop i mean this
is one of those end games where i think zagar can
actually like play pretty well with 12 seconds the
ideas become very simple right i mean if the live
square bishop comes out he would just okay well
that was a good choice but the moment the light
square bishop comes out that night is going to
become a monster on d5 and there will be nothing
that white can do about that night so i mean
black now has a very clear plan and rook d1 played
the a2 pawn can be captured by like what sagar
does he's like i'm not concerning myself with
pawns over there can't i really get away with
it let's just play simple moves that look strong
the 95 is also good because this bishop will never
get the full length of diagonal movie rook rook b8
just do it let's go now you can even play b5 b4 if
you want the position is getting better and better
this pawn's under attack obstacle bishop end game
simplistic but good for black yeah and look
actually eric's down to 15 seconds himself i
don't even notice that oh rook b2 clock moment
knight c3 first that's great rook b2 now bring
your rook in oh my god this position is so oh
now bishop c4 92 check maybe maybe 92 checks okay
well both are very similar yeah so you can play 92
take on d4 put a bishop on d3 it's good for black
but the clock what are you doing three i would
have preferred e3 but yeah oh e3 would have been
e3 would have been sick okay bishop d3
i would just do it two seconds you gotta
move you gotta move come on oh my gosh
point six second move ah i lost some time
oh look at him ah he sits back just oh he
can't believe it he played so well there too oh
that's just heartbreaking because that would
have even up the match and now it's a two-game
lead for eric rosen it's so hard to play with a
plus one increment i mean the plus one increment
exists but you know you still gotta pretty
much pre-move right every single move yeah
wow oh my god that was an intense game i mean
sagar is on form he is actually on form and and
that is very very exciting to see i mean played
an amazing game which is very unfortunate that the
time is part of the game and you do have to worry
about the clock sometimes yeah that game was about
what five seconds away from evening the score
and uh sagar just took a moment there we saw him
he was frustrated he calmed himself down he's
clearly in this match right this match is not
away from him but what we have been seeing is
as we creep closer close to the bullet portion
that's where eric will probably be at his best
and sagar has looked a bit shaky however there's
several more games left in the three plus one
this is sagar's time to make the most of it
and let me just position right now solid all
right we have a typical c4 d4 setup where you
control a lot of the board but it's it's closed
the position is really locked up right now
yeah this is one of those um it reminds me a
little bit of the kohli which is what i play
and it's very very solid and it doesn't really
give white an advantage but it's definitely not
a bad choice for blitz because you have very very
simple moves to make you know you go for this e4
plan you start putting your rooks towards the
center of the board you maybe look at a d5 pawn
break the ideas are not difficult and that's
sometimes all you really need in blitz because
time but time exists and we we we
found that out from the last game
we're not seeing a philosophical discussion
if time exists or if it's just a construct but
we see that sauer didn't need to waste any
more time to jump his knight in the center
but i don't like this because after pawn
takes bishop c5 now both of black's bishops
are going to be excellent the rook on d8
is well placed so i think that night jump
was really a problem for him now he's going to
have to fend off the initiative that eric has
and chad is like time exists forehead
true oh well i love you know riling
up the chat a little bit there so
let's see what's going on bishop d4 maybe i could
see a queen sack happening i would think about
sacrificing my queen for the bishop and the rook
but still that's something i would never do but
yeah for sure well look at the resulting position
right now black is just marching forward so maybe
objectively it still was good for black but this
at least practically speaking doesn't look very
fun yeah i'm not sure if i like this position
uh as late it just feels like everything is on
the background you know we actually don't have
a piece above the second rank that's beautiful
and you have that one pawn that's about to be
lost so that's not going to be very good news yeah
yeah i think there's raw in this game it was
going fine and then it just wasn't going fine
in like two moves yeah that 95 move it opened
the position up but in favorable terms for
black and black's pieces were situated perfectly
for it so that cyber needed to time it better
speaking of time he needed to put a rook on d1
and being able to counter instead he's in this
position where he's losing on time he's losing his
pawn e5 it looks like so he's in some big trouble
yeah he is taking his time to think in this
position um i mean it's hard it's i don't think
the choice of playing bishop takes d4 is the hard
one i think it's a realization that your position
is not amazing that's the hard thing to come to
terms with and realizing you have to either play
queen to g5 or queen e3 to protect your e-pawn um
and queen e3 just looks absolutely awful because
queen takes e3 and he has to play it
because otherwise you just lose that and
it's really more like putting a bandage on a
bleeding wound because like man those pawns are
you talked about last game how double pawns are
just so unfun in blitz games because you're always
worried about losing them and these are quite
possibly one of the worst double pawns i've ever
seen yeah the only good news and this is a small
bit of good news is that you can't actually attack
them the pawn e5 it's isolated it's weak but how
do you attack it you need your rook somehow to get
to the fifth rank which isn't quite possible so
i like what sagar has done all things considered
his position has been bad but the last bunch of
moves have been beneficial for him uh the rook's
probably gonna come to g2 i mean the rook on a1 is
tied down to the eight oh oh look at that tactical
fine no i was thinking the same thing i was
like wait how do i deal with rook d2 but rookie
one is so clever because once the rook takes the
bishop will capture back and then the rook trade
is offered and the a2 pawn is defended so this
might be sire getting out of the woods because
this e5 pawn it's weak but it can't be attacked
especially not in a king and pawn ending yeah
i think after rick takes d1 or kicks you one
bishop takes two i mean we're taking one bishop 61
sorry uh we have roxy one just trying to keep up
the pressure but soccer is like slowly easing his
way out of this and we can see erica's is like you
know biting his lip uh trying to think of ways to
keep his advantage up but this is actually
not that bad anymore right too bad for white
i mean black is still a little bit better but
yeah if you trade rooks you're not going to
win the game because your pawns are hard to
get so rook c3 makes sense but king d2 now
your king just comes right to the center attacks
protects the pawn if rook d3 just king over to e2
and you keep your pawns defended so i i really
believe that sagar has made his way out of this
i think his position is actually quite comfortable
and the one big problem i would say is these pawns
are on light squares so if you're not careful at
some moment some kind of bishop b1 bishop a2 and
just cutting down the pawns could happen but he
plays rook e2 instead which feels more passive
yep and here we're gonna see that king to e7
um i mean it's just going to become an end game
which will probably lead to a drop i mean time
is the one thing i'm going to be looking at now
we know uh sagar just lost the time the previous
game so he's probably well aware of his own clock
i would play f6 i would say i you know your
pawns look ugly but i want to get my king
up into the center of the board so f6 is what
i'm looking at in the near future for eric okay
i do think they're gonna go for the draw here
though they're gonna go for the repetition here
you think so eric's up so much
time i would play on if i were him
i would play on as eric too honestly um but eric
has well maybe maybe now we'll see something like
beef maybe b5 yeah i like that too just trying to
advance your pawns yep b5 and then if c takes b
c c takes b5 c takes b5 then you actually have
rook b5 and we can actually go for the e5 pawn
that's a great point so g4 well i like this
too because you're creating another advanced
pawn which could backfire for what look at this
rook h8 coming soon watch out for your h3 pawn
this looks very dangerous and you have 13 seconds
yeah i'm not sure about the bishop takes g6 move
oh that's a good move rick h2
you can at least save your pawn
and this e5 pawn is somehow still here like it
should have been captured it feels like eight
moves ago somehow but you could never get to it
so king up bring the king up yes king d2 is good
king d3 king e4 okay king c3 nice
oh direct is coming oh great move h5
take it over the pawn and then just try to
trade the pawns and then the rook might even
get around if you're not careful this row can
come to h8 into b8 so don't drop your a2 pawn
okay now he's dropping the eyes dropping e3 and e5
or is the rook i don't like this way of defending
it's so passive it's so passive king c3 give your
a2 one thing about rook end games what's the first
thing you learn about rook end games robert you
don't want to be defending passively yeah you
don't you want your pieces active a king d3 here
he actually might hold on qc3 back the king is
just going back and forth okay shade go over kj
go bring that rook around honestly white could
somehow win this game if black's not careful i
mean he he's been playing very active maybe we
might see yeah king to d7 and rook the e8 then
king c7 and rook f8 you just keep attacking
keep going okay okay that's also good okay rick
faye now yeah yep now king d4 do not allow the
black unison oh no he made he okay well black
didn't play king to c5d4 okay don't take him
oh yeah that's the issue now rook takes e5 oh okay
well i mean he'll do it soon it came before now
oh he's not taking on e5 i mean i guess he
really doesn't want to give up the f-bomb
oh oh oh no and sagar is just like i've had
enough of this right now but it's fortunate
for him that it's a time for a break they're
midway through the three plus one portion but
for a sagar you gotta feel for the guy he's
playing really well and credit to eric because
he kept up the pressure throughout that whole
game sure there were some moments where maybe
there was something to be done but he couldn't
break through he realized i'm not winning your
pawns but he kept creating weaknesses in sagar's
position and he didn't have enough time to hold
on for sure i mean part of chess is just annoying
your opponent enough until they eventually aren't
able to keep protecting everything right so you
know eric played a very very good game and sagar
almost held on all the way to the very end
but sally time is not on his side today so
yeah well it is time for us to go to our
break we'll be back soon with more action from
this saga shot eric rosen i'm not jim speech's
championship match brought to you by chess.com
all right and we are back for the second half of
the three plus one um and we just saw some very
very very exciting games between eric and sagar
and all i want to say is maybe after this break
maybe sagar has like freshened up his mind he's
gonna be very aware of his time because he's had
pretty decent positions the last couple of games
unfortunately he has lost to the clock and that is
a very very unfortunate way in a way to sort
of like lose in blitz but of course we all know
that's part of the game right so however we are
expecting to see um some pretty exciting things
what are you predicting well it's just very
difficult to know like how much time you use in
certain decisions because sagar is playing great
chess as is eric but i was spending too much time
and some moments you just need to be practical
that a good move played quickly is better than
the best move played slowly and we say this
every single time it's hard to internalize that
especially as somebody who you know studies the
game their entire life you're like wait i want to
always find the best move but when the situation
arises where you don't have time remaining to
find the best moves when you're winning or when
you have a good position then you're like okay
now i just need to play quickly and sometimes not
overthinking is producing the best chess for sure
definitely i hear you there um i mean honestly
in terms of playing blitz and like these
longer time control strategies all of these things
classical making the switch from classical or even
rapid into faster time controls is quite difficult
because as chess players right like robert said we
all want to find really good moves but sometimes
you realize hey sometimes i just need to find a
move and that may be what sagar needs to realize
in this moment i i have no doubt at all that his
intuition is amazing maybe he just needs to trust
himself a little bit more yes yeah we're about to
see the next game get underway and we'll see
how he handles this because he is down three
points he's still in this match and i hope he
doesn't just start sacrificing pieces for no
reason but he does need to get winning that's for
sure get winning i like i like the way you put it
i you know it's what else can be said he needs
to win games because he's down three and eric
is the favorite in the bullet portion but sagar
is playing very well so he has his chances
yeah for sure i'm excited um and we'll get
the games in just a moment now and here we go
d4 played by eric so we saw airplane c4 and now he
plays d4 we also hit e4 earlier and we're getting
a london system of course now if
you don't know about eric's london
then you've probably been living under a rock
um this is definitely one of eric's you know
favorite lines it's something that you've
definitely seen before play by him okay this is
actually a line i've not seen before i've never
seen when london where the queen gets onto c5
yeah there are some lines where the queen gets
here but usually it's when uh white wins material
because it's like a known blunderline it's not
this this is perfectly good for black look at this
you've established your center with d5 and e5 your
queen is absolutely fine being on the c5 square
and you can castle but if you cancel kingside
you lost the benefit of doubling your pawns which
is the open file so i think sagar's handled this
perfectly you know i might actually start playing
this line myself as black this is looking quite
exciting it looks great i mean there's nothing
to complain about in this position and for
sure you can just develop your knight to c6
or to d7 i'm not sure which is better square
he chooses d7 i guess to give the queen more
returning space to use the c file potentially
at some point so i just prefer black's position
uh very very comfortable stuff this is um we're
gonna see the rook come out i actually prefer
maybe work to d8 just because i kind of want to
push d4 at some point however i don't even know
if my idea is gonna work and yeah and i think in
part knight d7 i now that i'm thinking about it
the knight on c6 would be dominated by the pawn on
c3 the knight on d7 has a future on the c5 square
of the queen is to move out the way all right um
we do see white just relieving a little bit of
pressure in the center with e takes d5 i'm liking
knight takes d5 here or maybe even queen takes d5
i like queen 65 just because i don't want to give
up control over the e4 square i know that it won't
amount to anything but just that thought of the
queen of the bishop lining up and turned checking
my king makes me feel a little bit more cozy but
i also understand there's bishop c4 at some moment
so there are going to be tactics all right knight
e4 um this position is just so unfamiliar to
me i'm like trying to wrap my head around how
everything this position is going to work out
maybe maybe we play knight takes e4 feels like
an easier way out where you just like ah let's
just start swapping pieces going to that end game
um but i'm not sure if black actually maybe wants
to keep up the pressure in this position because
i definitely feel like black is the one with a
little bit of an edge you know he's the one with a
little bit more initiative yeah i think this pawn
e5 is the best situation and i see the evaluation
bar go crazy and then it goes back down so there
might be something available here but there's some
maybe tactics involving a knight takes e5 so if
you take on f6 first that's probably what it was
and i'm only helped by i see the evil bar going
up and down otherwise i mean rook 81 looks like
a perfectly normal move and that's the biggest
difference when the players are playing they have
no idea if they miss something unless they spot it
but they're not informed that there's something
available the biggest difference between seeing
an eval bar or knowing it's a tactic is well you
have to know it's a tactic before you can play it
definitely and here i mean we're just going
for a solid gameplay i kind of like this choice
coming from um you know this this opening
choice from soccer has been absolutely great he
is however still using quite a lot of time but i
mean eric sees a lot of time here too just white
doesn't really feel it doesn't feel like white has
a lot to do in this position so that's probably
where all the thought is going into i mean how do
you how do you improve your position here right
i do like that last move but black can just move
this knight out the way knight c5 was the choice
hitting the bishop protecting the pawn on b7
and i don't know i feel like both sides can be
comfortable in this position bishop
b5 looks reasonable this rook can come
to say d8 or something like that i'm not
sure who's better yeah rook aca here maybe
sorry i just had that cough there uh rook c8 is
possible for sure and yeah that makes sense you
protect over protect the knight and if
this pawn ever thinks about going to b4
your rook's on a good line with this pawn on
c3 so rook c8 definitely makes sense to me
yeah and uh oh wait e4 this is very aggressive
that's a pin so if you move the knight you lose
the rook but perhaps there's like a counter pin
with queen c4 the e4 pawn captures an f3 you
lose your knight your bishop on g4 rather so
or you could also play b4 which attacks them
that's yes that's true that knight is very
important yeah pretending because you can't
actually take on f3 right since um like robert
said they're nice yeah nice i honestly wasn't even
looking at the rook and the eight but now that you
suggested and then the move happened
like oh e takes f3 isn't the threat
it's a pit yeah it's a bit that means e4 was never
a good move to begin with yes for sure uh this is
a last pawn for black sadly yeah i think you
just have to accept that fact you can't keep
spending time though look at this it's you're
losing a pawn and you're down 35 seconds so just
play knight d7 or something i'm not sure if
that's good but you play the move and hope
that you can you know gather enough strength in
the position to fend off white's position oh what
i'm looking at sauger's face nope he shakes
his head he didn't see who was hanging
he's like me don't play like me don't do that
yeah he just didn't see the rook was hanging
i mean to be fair to be fair it's not very obvious
um the queen is on a very odd square on b5 i mean
you would hardly ever have a pin pawn on e4 right
like i this is probably one of the first time i've
ever seen a 10 pawn on e4 but oh that was a puzzle
rush room in there for sure it was and it's a full
extra rook if you're cyber you need to resign you
need to get more games going yeah you need this is
one of the strategies as well for these kind of
formats where there's still 15 minutes left in
the bank for games you got to play as many games
as you can or at least try to get those games in
that's true and he's back to his bishop g2 lines
getting the bishop on the longest diagonal and
eric spending a little time before playing knight
f6 so let's see if cyrus can whoa b5 stopping any
kind of c4 this is still it's a true opening
players like vladimir kramnik played it so you
know that it's i play this line as black i like
it a lot you you basically say no to the catalan
you say no c4 for you but at the same time by
extending your pawns so far they could become
targets but i do think this is a good strategy by
eric because sagar has been way too comfortable
in those catalan lines for sure and c3 this is
a good way of playing against this a5 protecting
the pawn now you can just play knight to d2 he
takes on v4 which gives you the outside pass pawn
and if you can get your knight to b3 you stop
black from playing c5 black would like to play
c5 so you don't have this backward pawn i really
like your explanations of all these openings i'm
learning too just like i hope everybody in chat is
learning how to play all these different openings
honestly eric's openings have been um maybe apart
from apart from his e4 bishop c4 queen e2 line
but that that one that one is a little bit
unique all of these other openings i feel
like have been super instructional today yeah and
i would say that sagar is handling it very well
uh for the most part i think he's been doing
uh he's holding his own in the opening stage
but he just spends too much time in critical
moments and that's what's holding him back and
bishop c4 closing down the c file
it makes sense i can just move
oh i can't go knight to d2 i dropped
my e2 pawn so i should not do that
just rookie one to defend the pawn i thought
the rook could also go to c1 to try to say
if i kick your bishop down goes this c7 pawn but
either way we're getting a tactical position now
i actually really like bishop takes b3 before
knight e4 because then i can just get c5 in so now
i'm wondering if like i think it's very important
to keep control of that c5 square right i mean c5
is always a very thematic palm push in the catalan
even if this is not quite the catalan um yes yeah
no you're not getting it right this bishop and
g2 is going to open up this knight's under attack
this bishop is under attack and now knight takes
b3 of course i would have preferred knight takes
d2 yeah he didn't want to give up that bishop and
now like especially because black is never ever
ever going to get c5 hand as long as white you
know kind of just plays rookie to c1 knight knight
c5 maybe and that c pawn is looking really weak of
course be careful you don't want to take c7 here
because your queen will be trapped after work to
c8 i'm going to show that really quickly because
it looks like a free pawn to most but where
does that queen go and no squares are available
to your queen over here so the queen is trapped
in the spot that's kind of crazy honestly yeah
knight c5 played the point i think
is that white will play for e4
if you take on c5 i can just take back but there
is a moment i can play e4 and help my bishop
and alternatively i can say wait i have an outside
pass pawn and i don't mind pushing it up the board
yeah this is um looking pretty comfy for white
honestly this is this did not go very much in
the favor of eric and i also think this is just
one of those positions that nobody really wants
to play as black because you're out here
defending you know you only got one minute
o'clock defending is always more difficult
than attacking in blitz games just because
you don't have natural moves to make you have
to always think about what your opponent's doing
you're always trying to respond to them
so that's very difficult yeah knight c4
that makes sense you say you're like you don't
want to sit passively you don't want to defend
but here that's what i was hinting at earlier e4
the knight needs the defense of the pawn so you're
just trying to take on d5 and remove the guard
but i guess he'll play you can still play e4 like
you can just go and try to open up this bishop
the bishop can also reroute to f1 eventually to
use the new diagonal but instead we see b3 which
is also a very good move yeah um here knight a5
we're going to eric should be trying to
get that c5 pawn push at some point and
you know we all have the saying that knights on
the rim are a little bit paper so that knight is
not happy on a5 we have also talked about however
about how knights are the best blockaders however
you kind of have to combine those two and be
like do i would i rather have my nine on the
rim while blockading or should it just be you
know somewhere more active right and i and this
is one of those moments where i wanted to be a
little bit more active right but you do make a
great point about the knight blockade is a great
block hitter because it still attacks over the
pieces so the b3 pawn needs to have an eye kept
on it and right now eric he's down on time he's
trying to figure out where does the queen trade
want to happen i didn't want to take on c5 to
allow the rook in and for white is it time for e4
is it finally time to do it no e3 which does make
sense though he's trying to keep the position
a bit tamer and now the king is on e7 i would
try to keep the queens on the board if i'm white
i would bring my queen back that king is in the
center here and it's not going to get checkmated
but it could fall victim to some kind of attack
yes for sure and i think these palm pushes are
we're just trying to get all the moves out you
know before before somebody has to commit to
something what does they call like in chess when
you when you just don't want to make your position
worse so you're just trying to like find those
moves that that are like potentially beneficial
don't really do much but most importantly they
just don't make your position worse yeah just
those kind of waiting moves yeah the waiting
moves exactly and those are hard to do it i think
black is taking over all of a sudden because
you can play for e5 you can play for knight b7
pawn c5 you finally get that pawn break and it's
not that black is that much better you have to
be careful but the position is favoring black the
trajectory here and look at the time it's about
even it's getting a little better for black i oh
and we get the c5 that we wanted yes and the thing
is a lot you can't take on d4 so there is a pin
to look out for with this rook on c8 so you
need to figure out how to move forward here
for black maybe it's rook c7 rook c8 but i guess
not because the palm is captured immediately
yeah i mean here for sure there is going
to be you know a bit of like key f1 move
the king over oh that knight is going to look
absolutely amazing on c3 i just realized that
yeah this is not pleasant but the thing about the
knight c3 is then the b3 pawn feels safer because
now it can't be attacked so even though that's
a great knight you're not attacking the pawn
anymore so move this bishop away i think bishop f3
i don't even want to give that up anymore and then
later in the game i'll think about pushing this
a pump but of course don't allow e4 check yeah
oh i i don't think i love that because it seems
committal now you're gonna have a harder time
pushing d4 but maybe this king comes to e5 you
push for d4 anyway and look at how quickly eric
is taking over this game yeah there's definitely
a lot of um pawns on light square so pause on
light squares when your opponent has lights where
bishop can go either can go in two ways you either
completely shut down the light square bishop
because all the pawns on that color or the light
square pawns become really really weak because
they're on the color flight skirt bishop you know
all right so um this is one of those moments when
i mean the position is objectively speaking fairly
very equal but i do think white has to be fairly
oh time clock clock clock clock there was 55 there
uh rook if i would have been nice but bishop you
made a good point these pawns watch out 0-7 give
me one free move and i get through pawns so king
can go back to f6 but look at white keeping the
opposition do not take that knight you hang your
rook oh he lost some time he lost some time no oh
he was fending it off so well it was going so
it was a draw and this is not the first time
this has happened oh no sorry oh no no no yeah
the time is not his friend it's not on his side
and these games have been very close but eric has
been moving more quickly and he's been finding the
resources necessary in the ensuing time trouble
so well done by eric and for sagar it's just
that's the kind of day it is maybe with some
more practice he'd be able to speed up and
manage his time better but right now it's been
all eric rosen yeah for sure i mean eric eric
is definitely popping off today with um his
his control of the position really i mean
summer was having these great positions but he
wasn't able to convert them and that part is
very unfortunate especially when you're playing so
well but i mean i i just hope that this motivates
sagar you know he's a very very strong player and
we've talked about how eric plays every day sagar
on the other hand we're a little less unfamiliar
uh with his history of online blitz chess so
honestly he's doing absolutely amazing yes and
you can tell that he hasn't played much given that
his rating is like 20 50. oh he's way underrated
he's so underrated for sure and what's happened
though in the last it was three and a half three
and a half in the last five games eric has won
all of them in the three plus one time control
because you start with less time when cyrus
goes in those deeper things he doesn't have
time remaining to figure out the rest and
that's been the tale of the match right now again
i like sagar's position with the black pieces
he's got his knight on d4 hitting this pawn on e2
that's already a really devastating tactic you can
put c6 you can play bishop h3 you have a nice
bishop on g7 the opening has gone sagar's way
i think black is going to enjoy this
position however he is down 30 seconds
oh no yeah foreshadowing what we could see oh yeah
it's a very good position for black i mean you
have everything set up for yourself bishop takes
you too necessary here yep 96 f5 things like that
you know the thematic moves we see
i like black's position there's also some ideas
with knight g5 and queen h3 if you're not careful
so already eric should be on the lookout
for that and find a way to counter it
the thing is f5 though it's so easy to play like
f5 knight g5 ideas he's spending a lot of time
on moves that um i feel like intuitively he could
be playing a lot faster but i think i think what
he's doing subconsciously is double checking and
double checking you know but it's people who have
played a lot of blitz we just instantly go because
you know that's that's kind of just what you do
and that's what happens when you don't play
regularly i mean i play some blitz online of
course but when i play in classical tournaments
longer times i spent so much time thinking if i
move that pawn is that going to create a permanent
weakness for me or is that just a good move
and then as you said you're triple checking the
position and spending too much time so f5 great
move he is now ahead on the clock we'll see if he
can score a victory from a good position right now
he can play d5 he can play g5 he can at some point
play h5 he has choices here i like it great yeah
just go forward here the major downside of playing
f4 is the e4 square becomes white but then you
have the d-pad going to d5 so i do like sagar's
position here he's playing quickly he's been
confidently and let's see if he can take it all
right i mean here we have so many possible moves
for for black kind of i kind of want to start
playing this like it's a king's indian maybe go
reckon 7 or a cafe and just start storming white's
kingside i think that's honestly the best um
wait for black to play just very natural moves
you know you potentially have this open open fo
that is wow okay i mean he's going for the attack
yeah he's going for the attack he's being very
aggressive just just take take on g3 how do i
where's that knockout you know like i could take
on g3 you take back my rook is in the right place
but then how do i actually go and checkmate you
that's right yeah this is a very very important
question i mean now the c5 could potentially be
leaked too so you could play like throw in a
rook c8 at some moment yeah that makes sense
queen c6 actually just attacks something
like that no nice little double attack here
hmm it's funny because i want to check with you
along the f file but sometimes the best attack
is creating a second avenue of attack instead of
just tunneling on the f-file let me make a move
like as you said rook c8 or queen c6 or something
of that nature that could benefit black's chances
so cigar thinking here sorry he's down under 45
seconds suddenly he has half the time of eric and
this we've seen this one before oh yeah we've
seen this one we know the story however i hope
the ending of this story is a little different
from the previous ones because i think cigar just
you know really deserves to get a good game
off unfortunately we've already mentioned this
clock the time is part of the game so uh having
good time usage is obviously going to impact yes
yeah in rook f7 it makes sense right protect b7
rook f8 coming and this is a move that he spent
45 seconds on he can't afford to spend 45 seconds
look at his clock so it just that's the tale of
this match is uh spending copious amounts of times
in positions that he understands very well and
for eric and he's really just giving a very few
chances like he's pouncing in opportune moments
he's playing some really exciting chess but he's
benefiting from cyber's mismanagement on the clock
queen g4 okay so objectively speaking i don't
think this is a very good move for white just
because they will double up the pawns and
you know and then that end game is going
to be looking pretty good for black especially
because it's going to be bishop versus knight
however sucker is spending so much time on this oh
my god he's being a bit of a perfectionist queen
six is a good move okay that's an amazing move
right it saves the queens attacks c5 it gives a
discovery with d4 check at some point but he spent
17 seconds and now he's down to 12 and a half
he needs to play moves with that more quickly but
let's see he has a promising position right now
eric is the one who's unsafe he could take on
f7 the rook will just replace the first rook
and then now the f files blacks for the taking so
i like cyber's position he just needs to keep up
the pace okay here we go rook f1 take maybe but i
know my queen just stayed protecting the g6 bomb
okay so d4 e4 okay i like that move king h7
instead of committing to any choice he puts his
king to safety he protects the pawn c5 is under
attack d4 i'll take it then i'll go queen a4 at
the end your pawn on d4 is weak so queen b4 i like
it bishop fa just go for the pawn just do it just
go come on bishop of eight there we go 3.9 seconds
left take that pawn okay queen is gonna be three
watch out for queen of seven oh just make a move
i know good move though queen f7 queen is gonna
oh no just go okay 2.3 seconds he needs to move
he's got two bars yes yes yes oh oh we're going
on the offensive now take on d3 remove that
take it take it okay two and a half seconds
pre-move it queen e3 check that's what you have
to learn how to do is pre-move here queen e3
it won't be a bad move no matter what happens g3
oh oh yeah he didn't have enough time but queenie
uh queen three was good fujitsu is winning
oh he's gonna lose g6 pawn no oh my gosh
oh no he got checked no ah and the time is up both
in this game and in the three plus one portion
how in the world that was such a good game
my soccer hurt it was such a good game
he if he just had like two more seconds two more
seconds maybe you know i just think he could have
oh my god and eric blanked him in that
section it was six nothing eric rosen
in the three minute plus one
second increment time patrol
i mean i mean even though the result is in the
in the in the three plus one time control is a
six zero that is not an accurate representation
of sagar's chess skills because as we all saw
he's playing absolute phenomenon phenomenal chess
time is just something he's probably not used
to um he's probably not used to playing three
plus one but he's playing absolutely amazing he
really is and that's why i tend not to focus too
much on the score like the result because they
didn't tell you how they played however this is
an elimination match so he needs to score we'll
see if he can right the ship it feels like it's
getting too little too late but we have the bullet
ahead stay tuned everybody we'll be right back
with this matchup between international master
eric rosen and international master segar shah
all right and we're back and we're going to be
diving into the bullet portion really really soon
i mean oh it's been a very very intense match so
far honestly like my heart rate is just sky high
um watching watching them battle it out with such
high quality games is honestly very exciting and
you know even though it's three plus one you
might think that the games are not very high
quality they indeed are um and it's just being
very unfortunate for sagar honestly that that
time is just ah some days it just it is just like
that right robert i'm sure we all have those days
we certainly do i know them very well not
that today is that day but kind of every
day is that day for me but uh you know it
has been very good chess you can see it from
uh from sagar he's playing well he's just playing
slowly and for eric he's also playing very well
and he has the lead on the clock so it's been sort
of balanced on the board throughout most of it
but that's what blitz is blitz isn't just about
oh let me find good moves every move no no let
me find good moves and do it so quickly so eric
deserves the all the credit in the world we do
feel sorry for soccer it doesn't feel nice to
lose on time a bunch of games like this but
eric has deserved every single game that
he's been winning he is pouncing and he's
opportunistic and in that last game there
he was able to survive in a way that most
people couldn't even dream of just to then
lay the checkmate and a win on the clock
and before we dive in the bullet portion i mean i
just want everybody to you know show support for
both players eric and sagar who are both playing
absolutely stellar chess we've talked plenty about
how sagar is very very prominent in the chess
community however he is most likely not playing
as much blitz and bullet as eric is you know so
um he is however putting up an absolutely amazing
fight and it's been an absolute pleasure to see
him play very very solid chess today and the real
question is are we going to see the stafford
gambit i guess he can't really play it because
sagar isn't playing e4 but when will we see those
vintage eric rosen gambit lines that's what i am
anticipating in the bullet and for sagar we'll
see if he just can play freely the stress of the
match can sometimes force your hand to shiver and
you won't play as fast as possible but with sort
of the match result it's you know looking like
it's out of hand maybe he can just move freely
yeah and uh this is not strict bullet this
is one plus one which is still very very
fast wait why is he spending so much time
i think his connection is struggling oh no
yeah uh he's got one bar that i see but he's
still moving and also his bullet rating is very
high his blitz rating was 22 something his bullet
rings near 2500 so maybe he's better bull than we
thought maybe i i love the way we put it i mean
i definitely think that maybe the connection is
causing a lot of issues for him at the start but
but we're off now we're we're we're doing okay now
uh he's making fast moves we're getting to
a very comfortable position for white here
structure yeah the b4 a4 b5 palm push is coming
in and these are the players we need to see in
bullet because it's so easy you know these five
move plans that you can make and there's not
really much your opponent can do it's just
easy moves to make while keeping your time
up eric however has only spent four seconds
and sagar is actually down to 30 seconds so
yeah i think you know sorry here he knows what
to do but he's trying to be perfect taking on
c6 at some point going rook after c1 you just go
after this pawn on c6 but he made a big decision
there because after f takes watch out for bishop
f5 hitting the queen and the rook on the diagonal
i definitely do like black's position a little bit
more now just because he has the pair of bishops
i think that can be very very strong and can be
you know quite literally game changing and get
wait wait wait 99 yeah hitting the queen hitting
the bishop oh that problem was pinned see that
oh no remember to always look for captures
right guys checks captures threats and that
capture is still possible but it's not as strong
because the end of it the bishop takes f3 so
queen h4 coming in for a checkmate watch out for
h2 don't play h3 the bishop will sacrifice itself
g3 look at those light squares though it's
not so pleasant but no checkmate for now
so rook fc1 and it feels like black should
have an attack but if you don't attack quickly
then white is just strategically
and structurally much better
yeah this is um rook takes f2 i think he
probably could have taken on f2 there all
the time and the time difference is just
crazy yeah ten seconds for white but he's
he's playing some good moves lately the
queen gets ready to start whatever best free
only way take this bishop off but there's going to
be a sack on g3 yeah we already know i mean queen
xg6 holds it for a little bit longer but this is
okay well the bishop takes g3 very very natural
mate checkmate oh no yeah this is a a brutal
finish but that's actually how the game was
going because eric you know he kept playing
with purpose there and sagar missed that
knight takes d5 that one little tactic and
after that the game was clearly in black's
favor yeah we're definitely seeing some very very
aggressive um gameplay from eric and this is the
kind of gameplay we we associ associate him with
usually so it's definitely very nice also i just
realized this is the karo khan breyer variation
i didn't realize there's another briar variation
uh i only know the one from the spanish
but chess.com is telling me that this is
another briar well i guess he was very flexible
as the chess player going through uh different
variations and here it it doesn't really look like
a caracon at all it looks like uh you know some
just solid positional game it looks like a briar
yeah and now knight takes e4 just take back if the
d takes we trade queens and bishop takes now i can
play f5 at some moment to challenge your bishop
on e4 but all right cigar is not uh he's not
committing anything so sagar goes knight to d7 and
he's moved knight to f6 he's playing casually
you know he's taking his his leisurely base um
all right he takes knight all right
okay so what now what now bishop e6 looks
reasonable the thing is i like i wanted
the long castle actually i was really cheering
for a long castle there you know so you can go
for an attack yeah that's that's why i cut away
you know we go on castle we play f4 we play f5
life is simple when you just push your pawns
up it's true it's simple in either direction
either you just go and checkmate or you know you
lose the game but either way it's true it's okay
yeah it's simple right like i'm with you and well
speaking of simple we've simplified the queens are
off the board this pawn on a2 didn't was that
not a free pawn am i um there could have been
some c4 stuff so oh true yeah it's it's yeah
you're right it's getting sneaky over here but
white's pawn structure is compromised with
these double pawns but you also have an open b
file that you can use to your advantage so i
would try to put a rook on b1 in the near future
for sure i mean here you know you just it's a very
solid position i i think this end game should be
objectively speaking of draw i don't see a wave
i don't like b5 because it undoubles the pawns
yep but it does give you a an eventual
attack on the c2 pawn right if you can
coordinate well enough rook c8 comes and that
could run but i like that move a4 really good move
and we're just trading everything off on the queen
side so your assessment of oh it should probably
be a draw that looks pretty accurate but i'm
looking at the clock situation we're getting into
time trouble and we know how those games have gone
yep okay so we have just a sort of clamp for both
sides the c2 pawn is stuck in place the b5 pawn
was under attack and brooke here i'm i'm wondering
nemo at some point there's like a rook b7 and i
take over the seventh rank and black's king can
be in big trouble i honestly don't really think so
um i think white's a little bit too tied down now
with with defending his his own pawns i do like
black's position here i think it's quite active
but maybe now rook b7 because oh nice look at that
like see eric is finding these moments where that
was hanging for one move it just happened but he
noted the difference in the position and he just
takes that pawn and now he's up and you know
i think eric did a lot of puzzle rush recently
it seems to be time time i i mean it's
it's objective oh his rating was still
um provisionary right because i just saw a minus
42 for sagar so he doesn't really play that much
yeah bullet but um i mean black could potentially
hold this end game i don't think it's fully
lost yet it's just very very difficult for
sure right but time went out so now it is
lost and well eric keeps on winning his bullet
rating is above 2600 so he's thriving in this
match it's funny because he started off on fire he
was three and a half one and a half ahead and then
sagar went two games in a row okay wait a sec
this is a match and eric said no no it's not
like i'm gonna just take all the next bunch of
games so he's won eight games in a row for sagar
the time control the time trouble he's never
been his friend and also the internet troubles
is also not his friend yeah and i think that's
why the clock is paused for a moment we're just
trying to resolve the lag uh for sagar because
yeah it has been a struggle with his connection
um so you know this match still has nearly 18
minutes left is it possible for sarah to win the
match still he'd have to win eight games in a row
there's probably not enough time mathematically
speaking uh if you know the games go in normal
distance so yeah it seems that eric rosen will
take this match and if that happens or when that
happens i should say nemo in the bracket it means
that he goes on to face levy rosman so what do
you think of that matchup of gotham chess versus
international master rosen i think that this is
a matchup that all the fans have been waiting for
i think i mean obviously you know gotham
chess versus uh uh eric yeah this is gonna
be really exciting because not only you know
are they really big personalities on twitch
and youtube they also have very interesting
game styles right yeah no it's it's going to
be a matchup of fan bases that's what i'm really
interested in to see how loud the fan bases cheer
for their respective parties there's definitely
overlap you know of course people can like more
than one person but when it's a match of just
two players somebody has to win and eric rosen
versus levy rosman that would be a fun one this
is one that i'm definitely going to be following
yes indeed so we think we're about to resume
the play here hopefully the connection issues
have been resolved that the lag is minimized and
for sagar let's hope that he can get a few good
bullet games in before the end of the match just
to feel like you end on a good note it has not
been going his way since the five minute portion
he probably wishes that hey can we just play
that 5-1 over and over again let's keep with
that he definitely wants to buy one back yes
and this is exactly what happens
when you're not an online player so
while we have a moment i just want to remind
everybody of a great upcoming event it is the fee
day online world corporate chess championship and
there's still time to register so if you're part
of a company and you have a bunch of players that
want to take part do get involved get register
just do a quick google search find out the how
to do so but it will be february 19th to 21st
wait if i'm part of just.com am i allowed to
do it too i don't think that chess companies
are taking part i think this is more for other
types of companies okay yeah i think the chess
companies would win those kind of competitions but
i do know i do know that companies are allowed to
have a ringer they're allowed to bring on one
player and the maximum rating for that player
is uh one player over 2500 i should say so you
can bring on a player so nemo if you find a
company that needs a player you can go ahead and
slide you guys already know what i'm gonna do
are you gonna start your own
company like yeah i'll just start my
you're gonna have employees you know somehow
i'm one of your employees yeah yeah wait i'm
thinking now i'm thinking i i have things planned
the uh the bow test sister is part of it nemo llc
yeah exactly i'm here for it so yes
if you're you do like chess if your uh
your company wants to get involved you
can register i think the registrations
are still available for a few more days but
there will be some strong teams out there because
in the new york city corporate chess league there
are teams like a couple international masters on
them i know google of course well they're a huge
company they have many strong players but it's
going to be a good event this is going to be very
exciting i'm excited to watch this and it's going
to be like there's going to be podcasts this oh
my god so much amazing chess content coming up
for sure well while we resolve
these issues i think we're going
to take a quick break just to allow the players
to figure this out and when we return we will have
the finale of this bullet portion of this
matchup between eric rosen and cyber shot
all right and we are back the game has
already started and this is uh uh an
opening that sagar is pretty familiar with right
we've seen this already twice happen at least
and yeah eric plays this d4 line so it's a
long time since we've seen this but we like
the position that sagar was able to get although
you like initially black setup which i can buy
but in that game something went wrong for
eric along the way and then white got that
c5 like knight into the d6 square so we'll
see how eric hansel handles it this time
i mean i definitely think oh wait this is a
tactic but does the tactic work let's see okay
so this is wilds if you castle he'll take on c6
and then take on e5 but black may be down a pawn
but a ton of compensation thanks to this light
square bishop here we go we have liftoff here wow
this is this has become very complex i mean sagar
came back from the break and just suddenly started
playing super aggressive openings i like this yeah
he's down eight points he needs to win the games
and he's won upon his knights coming to e4 what
attack does black have right you need to attack
black has well i mean the the the a8 to h1
diagonal might be a little weak but yeah
just get that bishop there but he moved his bishop
to f5 did eric and so now the knight just gladly
stepped into e4 the queen can come to well not to
f3 anymore because the b2 pawn is hanging but at
some point that queen could consider going there
or hey why not let's trade queens i'm open pawn
this looks great for white definitely very
solid position i mean this is one of the first
times i think in the match when we've seen eric
actually lower on time so he's definitely sweating
a little bit and i think c5 here is extremely
strong because then you get your knight to d6
we've already seen the knight to d6 um theme
before but this one's gonna be even stronger
yeah i'm looking at f5 as well to try to go
after this bishop on g6 but i dropped my c5
so queen c4 let's be wise about this there
it is protect the pawn on c5 attack the
pawn on d4 maybe this rook can come to e7
pawn to f5 white's attack is really quick
yup definitely very very nice position queen
takes d4 also possible queen xb2 sure okay i mean
we don't really care too much about the pawns at
this point i mean when you're going for checkmate
pawns are uh secondary you know i'm with you
there and rook be that's a good move by eric
eric has done a really good job staying in this
game queen c3 offering the queen trade so that the
king feels safer on h8 and white does have plenty
of time here but look at that advantage slipping
i saw the eval bar just jump down there watch out
for rook to b2 and check me along the second rank
think rook to b2 yeah we're just gonna queen e2 is
forced here or or i mean rookie two is also pretty
okay king g2 maybe yeah queen e2 though i like
your move just retreat oh no wait no one would go
there's no way we're drawing this right i mean
this is the one chance you have for winning and
there's no we can't draw this and eric played
for a win he went queen c2 instead of queen
d2 so if he loses it's unintended back
to e2 e7 e2 then you win this bishop oh
nope okay i said we're gonna hear your trade wait
wait it's a free road take it okay finally sagar
gets this one wait wait wait what wait what's like
are you doing some meat oh my god oh okay it was
it was just lag it was just like okay oh my god i
was so stressed there for a moment oh my gosh and
eric put up great defense in that game like that
the fact that he lost the pawn but then drummed up
all of his counter play with his queen and his
rook yeah that was really well done but seller
had the time to calculate that's why time is
so important that was a very very clean game
and by the way look at cyrus rating he went from
23.80 whatever to gotta love that provisional
rating yeah it has not stabilized because he
hasn't played enough games and he's stabilized
his position right now for black is very solid
here white though doing well with the bishop on
c4 a little bit more active and moves like h6
you think what has changed the g6 f5 squares at
some point knight coming into the game on this
side but queen b1 queen a2 is eric's first stop
okay so queen a2 go for the pawn in 95. this is
a very very easy easy um i was just there for a
moment i was thinking about 95 and i realized the
queen protects f7 anyways yeah and the knight at
c5 is nice because at some point you can just
put a piece on e6 and you can start trading off
d5 getting sharp is there going to be some kind
of sack here whoa we have cyber shot ready to
play queen f4 bishop d6 let's go for that what
happened during that break i'm sorry what did i
miss yeah what has he been fed like what kind of
food has he been eating during the break he's like
had a couple of protein bars and he's just ready
for all ready to go like like he like we went we
before the break sagar was you know using so much
time playing like slow chess and now it's just
wow like this is a beautiful chest like it's
just so aggressive every move is with purpose
mm-hmm giving up all these pawns in the queen side
the dark squares are more important to me wait are
we should we get the names swapped or something
you know we're good here queen b6
bishop's e5 to follow if king to h1
there might be knight h5 into the g3 square
eventually you have to watch out for rook 66
no i i saw it coming the rook won't follow and the
king is in trouble no matter where the queen goes
this rook can either take this knight
with check or the rook and go elsewhere
to win the queen so as that's called the
casters jinx or the commentators curse you know
um you know we won't praise the players anymore
the players are really just not doing anything
special it's just him it's kind of blah yeah
they're they just they're just you know playing
normal chess this is stuff you would see every
single day on chess.com yeah you know moves are
being made the bishop is a bishop the knight
is a knight oh the queen is a queen and that
queen is going to be a little bit gone yeah no
rook takes d5 but sadly you get part two now
you take the knight that was in the way and now
the rook moves again and the king is in check
oh gosh this is no this is that was what a good
game though it was going great until it didn't go
that great and credit to eric he was super alert
he had a bad position he knew that sagar was had
the upper hand and was playing really well and
yet he stayed focused and he saw rook takes e6
and he pounced as soon as available i've used that
word pounced many times but that's because i feel
like that's what eric is doing here he is getting
some good positions where he just puts sagger away
and then other times when it's complicated
and stressful he's ready for the tactics when
they become available to him yeah eric is playing
absolutely um phenomenon phenomenal chess for sure
wow english is very difficult i've been like
trying to conjugate english words and for some
reason i'm struggling i just say the base form
of it and i'm like wait that is not quite correct
you know nobody nobody can tell the difference
just don't bring any attention to it you're good
you're good yeah it's fine it's fine okay well we
have a situation where black is a pawn ahead but
i would be very nervous about this bishop on g2
hitting the pawn on c6 threatening a takes b5 the
rook is undefended so some kind of like white's
position is so good it's like sagar is getting
into such good positions and i'm just like oh my
god i'm so happy for him you know yeah and he does
have time right now 41 seconds to 31 at this point
he's up 10 seconds knight 64 is a free pawn the
rook protected b5 but the rook is not defended you
want to look whenever their pieces in a row with
each other what happens when the piece in between
them moves out the way unfortunately soccer plays
e4 which is a great move very tempting takes c6 oh
my gosh an e5 i see you i see you with the tactics
but this is not what sucker wanted because queen
d6 can be played trying to fix the pawn structure
and get a past pawn but if black doesn't take then
white remains down a pawn yeah there's just so
many like you know exciting tactical moves that
can happen in these positions um i mean here's c5
or rookie it's also reasonable but this bishop
on g2 anymore that's yeah that's the sag bishop
very do not take on f5 do not take on f5 although
f6 becomes scary so you have to be on the lookout
for f6 in a quick attack oh no you took on f5
that bishop is now a bishop again it's regained
its former glory yeah now it's a bishop again it
was going to be a tall pawn but now it's a bishop
we have four watch out for e6 f6 the rook on b8
is not defended so i like the queen of four it's
trying to play for tricks 24 is also good hitting
c6 f6 still possibly eight seconds barely got that
move off e6 is possible f6 is possible even what's
going on here a lot of things is happening i mean
eric is being super aggressive he has three
seconds twenty five quid four age four yeah that's
mate and the queen's hanging yeah oh he realizes
that immediately and just has to go i mean
sagar is going to check mate black into moves
oh my god eric was playing really well i mean
he he had a bad position coming out of the
opening and he he was like holding it but man
i love that i love it he smiles too he knows
what he's doing yeah he's just he's having a
good time and eric is like he's a comedian at
the board and he's one of those like he he just
it doesn't seem like he's joking and even when
he makes jokes he just has this i don't even
know how to put he's just i wish i had the
word it's a very high brow sense of humor
but eric is awesome and sagar he's a natural he
is he is and sagar is you know he's great you know
he's getting back some some wins here he's gonna
feel better about things watch out for e4 okay the
knights under attack with e4 is a typical tactic
to win the knight in c3 but when analyzing like
with commentating bullet games all i'm looking
at is can he take here can you take that you know
it's just like it just becomes constant
tactics it's like doing mini puzzle rush
yes and there it is i see them to deadpan
here that's what i was looking for it is very
difficult everybody to talk chess try to come up
with vocabulary words but thank you deadpan humor
i really like eric's sense of humor i've known him
for a long time he's actually a great photographer
for those who may not know that and he is often
a journalist at many of the top events so he'll
play blitz with the players in the free time and
he's just a great guy so i know eric quite well
and and now well he's getting to know sagar quite
well and he plays f4 saying hey your turn to think
you're in time trouble i'm up 20 seconds and look
at this position g4 comes to mind the knight on
g6 isn't defending bishop d5 check knight
to d5 use all the squares available to you
this is um looking pretty good to see white
for eric it's um definitely one of those
i mean could've just taken on a five two i'm sure
but i i feel like at this point eric doesn't want
that pawn anymore he just wants to absolutely
crush black knight c6 position yeah this is what
i'm talking about it's so hard to make a move in
this position it's like eric is playing played
this game absolutely beautifully he came out of
the opening with a tiny bit of edge yeah black
played a little too passively played a little too
slow and then all of a sudden this is what happens
and the matchup it's you know out of control
at this point but if this were a close match
this is the moment where you just resign right
you just try to get more games going but for
uh sagar he's it doesn't matter in terms of the
match score there's a little bit of prize you know
have some fun he said are you not entertained
and the answer is yes sorry my apologies
uh but yeah the this knight in c6 was the hero
it forked and then won the rook and now it's
back on c6 perfectly happy is that queen's
like almost trapped but has the g5 square
and all right f5 forking more this is the game of
forks yeah this is uh this was a bit of a painful
game eric played absolutely beautifully yes
eric's in great shape right now and you know i
i i want to say that it's one of these matches
where the story line often is oh sucker lost
on time and he had good positions that's true he
did have good positions and he has lost some time
but eric deserves so much credit for putting
pressure on the board and the clock even
when he's been in trouble he has been the most
resourceful player that you can possibly imagine
finding these tactical uh moves that save the day
just saying you know even if i'm lost objectively
we got to keep the game going and as if you
keep the game going longer and longer your
chances to survive increase and that's something
we all really need to learn from right it's um
not giving up when you're just worse and instead
just fighting back and playing for that win
eric being able to convert all like so many
positions in when she was worse into a win that
is a lot like that is skill right there oh 100 and
you hear this from the top players all the time
uh because they get in bad positions too whether
it's magnus within tsukaru but the ability to
be resourceful and to dig deep and never give up
that's an essential part of speeches in particular
and chess more generally so look at eric when
is knight to t5 stole upon c4 his queen is in
line with a rook but there's nothing you can do
to exploit that so you're up upon b2 is hanging
the bishop and the queen lined up perfectly it's
going to be another win for air maybe three oh
no another fork yeah now you can just take them
be careful with those knights in bullet chests
eric's knights you know he's just been
using them perfectly in this match
and well does what i even have a move
here i'm trying to come up with something
so hard it's something that's what king h1
was played yeah as well as waiting moves
yeah bishop a6 take on e4 take over the
f file this is uh pretty straightforward
yeah sagar is probably tired it doesn't late
by him but he's not going to use it as an excuse
and the thing he's going to say is eric played
great and my time management was bad and for sure
eric played great yes eric just played absolutely
beautiful chess and look at this
bishop d3 take on a5 with the queen
all of your pieces in the game right now for
black and you are up material so yeah this one uh
might be a go next angle not much to say here
other than you know why it's just kind of
trying to hang on fortunately not a lot of moves
are even like possible to complete like you you
know you can't barely move your pieces you know
everything just okay well ricky one here is or
or or anything really yeah queen g3 first rookie
one next rook e1 actually still was possible there
because of the checkmate on the dark square there
goes that rook and there goes another victory for
eric rosen oh oh my god okay well eric is just
running away with this match i mean 14.5 to 5.5
yes that's uh oh he's thinking a little bit
second move are we gonna get this again we
are we're gonna get this funky bishop c4 but
no queen e2 this time so it's probably gonna
go into the periods right yes and it's got
like these vibes of a potential king's gambit
that was declined but i like what sagar is doing
a5 going on the queen side because you know white
is going to strike in the king side at some point
so get activity while you can on the queen side
okay give the knight to 7 knight c5 i mean this
position is just looking pretty solid for white
yep but b3 bishop way to be together that's like
you play the spanish often right and sometimes
that move you sacrifice a pawn just to shut
down the bishop this is one of those moments b3
i wouldn't think you have a rewrite or bishop to
b1 and then becomes a big pain yep and he's going
way too familiar with this i think we know that
b3 is coming why else put your rook on b8 yeah
i wonder what rugby could be for there it is but
now this bishop is going to come it's like d4 a3
and then the pawn on b2 is defended which means a2
is followed so it's upon sacrifice at this point
and black is not thrilled about that even though
he got the bishop off the board yep now we might
see uh some c5 i mean i think this is very good
for for wyatt like you have the center um you
have a really weak a5 pawn to go attack you have
possibilities to expand on the king's side like
this is a dream position for white it certainly
is and it goes to show that cyborg didn't want to
sacrifice material but sometimes that safer method
causes you more problems because look at this
he'd end up losing the material anyway so that
temporary pawn sacrifice with b3 was justified
and now knight d5 is a threat to probably e6 to
stop it but when you play e6 the dark squares on
your king side become weaker so e5 knight oh okay
g4 trying to kick the knight away to go knight d5
wow just going to go check my name all right
well i wonder what rook h3 could be for i
don't know you tell me maybe maybe we we want
to you know just march our pawns up the board
i love f5 here i see pawn i push pawn and i like
what oh that's a pin knight and the knight can't
be defended well rick kicks h5 here okay true
the knight is hanging here but at least you
quick counter shot into point take c3 and then c2
is hanging can i take on c2 no rookie wait sweet
take c2 well there was rook g6 that scared me he's
five seconds left all right true yeah 30 seconds
to five seconds so i mean there's actually a lot
of chances here from oh wait a minute wait whoa
why don't you just take off that was a free
pawn you want that pawn i promise you you want
it king king f8 run your king away and take
on h5 saga is winning this week 1.8 seconds
i would play like queen takes e6 or something
to flag them just try to win on time you know
but the thing is like you probably you know
usually in these kind of positions i pre-moved
every single capture yeah preview vertically tried
because there's nothing white can do about it so
even if queen queen should be terrible because
rick h5s comes with a chat eric is using all
this time now yep but he's trying to figure out
a way to win on the clock and king there queen
each one good move queens for it just go just go
all right if queen if one is working three worker
three oh i missed it right three would have won
the queen i've had that lined up and now black is
even immaterial is that right i can't count
quickly enough even material yes even material
oh my gosh and even on the clock rook 8 coming
to win the a5 pawn oh i don't like this palm push
yeah because king of d4 check and you can win the
f4 7 though rook f6 now is going to win for white
i like the king coming in though can you eat
three keys trying to check me he's trying to check
king d4 go no it's too slow though okay yeah
it's unfortunate yeah rook f2 you're gonna
lose g6 you can take out four maybe there's some
chances to draw this but you're down two pawns
yeah i mean it's very difficult and that pawn that
passer is uh rookie two wait rookie two and then a
four a three wait it's a draw again yeah somehow
sagar escaped he's also playing really quickly
like he he had one second and now he has six
seconds so he is warming up yeah he's in pre-movie
he's getting his bullet skills back and it's
eric who's the one in more time trouble right now
all right so king b5 the time scramble there was
just crazy oh wait this is winning again oh never
gets to f4 that's huge oh no yeah and then you're
gonna get the a pawn and then two pawns and this
is winning yep and you can even play with like
c4 check because the king will have to go away
now king two ah you just go don't take an a4 oh
actually you can because it's not me rookie seven
pc4 back just go kc4 try to check my him try
to check him in oh king c5 would have been
cute there yeah so it's going to be a win for
eric to cap things up unless he lose on time
always possible but no soccer all the time oh
what an intense match wow well we need to go to
break uh sorry to cut you off there you know but
we need to go to break so we get the players in
we can interview them hear their thoughts we'll
be right back with eric and sagar sounds good
and we are back with the players after was a
very hard-fought match congratulations eric
you played really well uh so i'd like to start
with you uh the match was tied three and a half
three and a half after the five minute portion
what do you think went right for you after that um
that's a good question i mean i started winning
games uh consistently which definitely helped
um i think the shorter the time control
the more of an advantage i had i think i
i was able to avoid flagging in some of these
um these crazy time scrambles and that can uh
that can definitely play a big role so uh yeah
i was happy with uh the later stage of the match
for sure and sagar what about you
what on your end did you feel like
went wrong i would guess time management would
be part of it but can you maybe explain to people
what it's like shifting roles from somebody who
talks about chess often to playing it yourself
yeah i mean i was looking forward to this
match uh very much i know that all the chess
knowledge that you gain by you know writing
stuff analyzing games commentating does not
guarantee you a good performance because of the
practical playing skills are lacking so i tried to
cover them in the last 20 days or so i
tried to play a bit i tried to train myself
i think if i had not trained myself i would
have done worse than this so so i guess a
little bit of more training maybe a month
or so more could make this match closer but
i think when um when the time was running low uh
eric was playing very well and i think full credit
to him for for winning this match yeah no we just
want to say to you sagar um we both were very
very impressed with your level of gameplay and you
know we talked extensively about your involvement
you know in the greater chess community and you
know watching you play a lot of the games and
having many many good positions but then losing a
little on time that that that was very unfortunate
i thought uh eric made very
good good use of his knights uh
when he would close the positions and then
you know sort of uh no lights are very tricky
he made sure nothing was hanging and you know i
i when i tried to over push or something then i
would get trapped or uh somehow hang something
so so that was uh one of the recurring themes
in the match yeah i think knights are more of
a like a better piece than a bishop in in low
time situations sometimes even trickier than
a rook so have to value them more in blitz
for sure and well eric a question for you
because you are willing to mix and match
different openings it seems so what was your
preparation like for this match and i mean you
seem to really concentrate on some aggressive
lines at points and then other times you're a
bit more solid so what was your sort of
mindset going in and how you would play
sure um i mean a big part of my preparation
i don't know if anyone or everyone knows
this but uh sagar streamed a lot of his kind
of training sessions with uh with adivan a
strong grand master so i i tuned into a bunch
of those and tried to try it he did homework
stream snipes well for one of them i joined
and then like the moment i joined they
they were panicking saying like eric rosen's
in the chat i was wondering like how they
could tell because i can't really tell on
youtube but someone was like impersonating
me on youtube exactly so um but i was still
watching i didn't want to say anything though
but they were they were super instructive
like it's super interesting to
watch like an international master get a lesson
from a grand master and they weren't doing so
much opening preparation but i still got a
sense for uh for sagar style and they were
trying to scout out my weaknesses so um so yeah
i was trying to uh to to make games exciting as
exciting as possible to get kind of my style yeah
i also checked your game with irene yesterday and
you know so we we both tried to get to know each
other and also adipan i would like to thank him he
helped me a lot in this match and it was also my
wife here she was following all the games while
they were happening and so in the break i would
go and ask her if you know is there something
that i can improve upon and then she would suggest
me so maybe that actually helped in one of those
games where uh the catalan game where i played
uh queen d3 i improved with quindy too so
that's so i know yeah unfortunately i
don't have a wife to help me with that
well i actually have a question the follow-up
question here because you're just uh talking
about uh working with adiban um and you know you
do a lot of journalism i've known about your work
and followed you for a long time but how much
work do you put into getting better yourself
as a player because there's a big difference of
course between commentating i know from experience
i'm not improving as a player when i'm
commentating and doing all this stuff but
you need to focus on your own chess so how much
are you doing and what is that experience like
well i i was doing nothing much because when when
there is work i i just don't commentate i also
have a a company to run so it's like an entire
organization with lot of people working together
so i specifically worked for this event like two
days i did not do any videos or any articles or
something so the last two days was very intensive
i prepared all the openings and everything
so i i think that it's it's different like
with regular commentating and annotating
you can really get a good feel for chess but uh if
you then mix it up with regular practice every day
then you can improve but i think the priorities
are set you know like you have to do some i have
to make sure i do some other things so i'm not
able to dedicate that time to polishing my skills
but uh you know every time i play such
a tournament uh it inspires me to start
preparing again so i want to thank chess.com
uh for for inviting me to such an event and uh
yeah last uh 20 to 30 days were great fun you know
preparing for this for sure and i guess eric you
know we know it's getting late for both you well
for you in particular sagar and eric we appreciate
your time but question for you you play against
levy rosman in the next match what do you expect
from that how do you see your chances yeah i'm
not sure um i'll have to maybe start preparing
uh levy i've known for for a long time we're good
friends we're kind of rivals a few weeks ago he
called me out on twitter wanting to to face me
in chess boxing and i'm not really into contact
sports and i don't really like hurting people
physically so i'll take your spot i'll fight levy
oh if you want to yeah you can play him in chess
i'll do the boxing part so i'm gonna do yeah
more uh more chest preparation can take him down
boxing that would be better let's go well you are
both two of the nicest people in chess great
ambassadors for the game we really appreciate you
taking time with with us after a very stressful
and tough match so thank you both congrats to
you eric and sagar again thank you for joining
us we hope to see you back in more competitions
thank you thank you robert thank you and uh i also
want to thank all the viewers who are supporting
also vidit was streaming and there were a lot of
people watching it uh so sorry for losing so many
games on time but thank you for supporting me
no thank you very much for taking your time out
both of you to play thanks yeah thank you so
there you have it the quarterfinals are set eric
rosen moves on to face levee rosin we heard his
thoughts and nemo i just have to say they are so
wholesome that was an amazingly friendly interview
they have so much mutual respect for one another
eric saying hey i actually was watching his
learning experience his coaching sessions and
i was learning through that so it's really nice to
hear how even super strong players international
masters they have a lot to learn they're working
on their game every single day when they have
a match coming up so i really appreciate that
insight yeah i mean honestly i think the most
maybe heartwarming thing for me was how much
effort really um both of the players put into this
match you know um like just how much like like
cigars explained that he took days off uh from
work and we we all have talked about how he he's
mentioned himself he has the company to run he has
a million other things to do but he really
was invested in playing today and that is like
you know results are one thing but kind
of like hearing those kind of stories
like makes me feel really good you know yeah and
um of course for eric as well i've played eric and
match before he's actually told me he's prepared
as well so it's just always hearing about these
chess players and how they're always looking to
be the best that they can be that is wholesome
and i love how motivated sagar is like he wants to
play more chess now he lost and he lost by quite a
large margin but he's like no let's keep going i
want to get back into this and i love that about
chess and it's a good reminder that these players
have been studying chess working on their game for
many many years and it's hard to just go and play
so when you have an engine by your side you know
even we as commentators we have the evaluation
bar it becomes easier it's not stressful and i
know from experience that when you jump right back
into it it can be difficult so thanks to both of
those players nemo thanks to you for joining me
for what was a great match for having me thank you
and we want to thank all of our viewers of course
for sticking with us tuning in and enjoying the
show there's more chess coming your way title
tuesday's about to begin so i think we got to
sign off get out of here and the title players
it's their time to shine all right see you guys
you